uh uh
foreign
i know it's wrong
but i don't care
the fire is strong
but i
is
about it is
think about
think about it later
is
think about it
is
so
do
knight d4 king d3 kings c4 droid great
wow what a save by uh
yeah wow what a fighting spirit
who has magnus mistrucks he won let's
check the camera
it seems so right this looks like he's
missed it
whoops he has missed it yeah
yeah you can see his face
uh
so
hello everybody and welcome to our
final day of the round robin section of
the legends of chess event it's been a
fantastic tournament so far and today we
decide who are the four semi-finalists
it's going to be goodbye for six players
and four
go through before we start let's just
rewind
our memories and refresh our memories
actually about how the tour has gone so
far
so we started the magnus the one million
dollar magnus carlson chester started
with the magnus carson invitational
which was won by magnus carlsen i know
ridiculous
uh but he's just too good he's just too
good
but not unbeatable because in the
linderis abbey rapid in a sensational
semi-finals
hikaru nakamura beat magnus carlson
qualified for the finals with duboff
daniel dubov won the second leg of the
magnus carlson chester
we went on to the chesapeal masters
which again
which was basically magnus carlsen and
anish giri
literally willing the universe to do
what they wanted and what all of us
wanted
we had an epic final between the two
when magnus carlsen stole the show and
now here we are
at the legends of chess the very last
day of the round robin stage
where it's been in each play each with
four games consisting of a match in case
they're played on a rapid format with 15
minutes plus 10 seconds and if it's been
a tie we've seen the games go into an
armageddon for the semi-finals uh the
format remains pretty much the same but
the difference is that
it's going to be a best of three so
we're still going to have four game
mini matches played every day but it's
going to be over a course of
three days uh as a best of three and the
big change is going to be that before we
go on to an armageddon
we are going to be we are going to have
two games of blitz
five minutes plus three seconds a lot of
you have been asking how are the colors
for the armageddon picked
and uh just just to tell you the format
first for the armageddon
white gets an extra minute so he gets
time odds but black gets
result odds which means if it's a draw
then black
goes through all right um
yes so how are the colors picked for the
armageddon in
in the preliminary stages the colors
were decided
by the by the seeding so there was a
drawing of lots and those who picked one
to five
got the opportunity to decide their
color for the armageddon
but in the knockout stages it's going to
be decided on where they finished
in this round robin so it is it is
important
to qualify but also to see what placing
you get
the pairings are going to be the one who
finishes first which isn't going to be
magnus carlsen he cannot be caught up so
it's gonna be one versus four and two
versus three
talking about the semi-finals let's take
a look at the current standings and what
the situation
is all right so magnus carlsen yeah
nepal nyatri
and anish have confirmed their spot
sealed the deal there
these three have qualified for the
semi-finals the last spot
the fight is between peter swiddler and
vladimir kramnik peter swedler looking
solid
in his uh in his race to the semis and
this is the situation
so if vlad has an outside chance
of qualifying what he needs to do today
is
not going to be easy one he needs to
beat magnus carlsen
in the rapid portion of today's match
armageddon only gets him two points and
that's not going to be enough
so he needs to score three points to
take over
peter swiddler and catch up with anish
with 15 points
that's not all anish also
peter swiddler needs to lose to aneesh
for vlad
to win in that case um yes but first
task up ahead against that
is going to be his match up against
magnus and trying to score that win
uh let's just go back to the standings
for a second
yeah and and the other players vassal
ivan chuck what a win he had yesterday
against anish kerry he's
he's shown tremendous creative play here
but unfortunately he does not have a
shot to qualify
been an absolute disastrous of a
tournament for vishyana and dingler and
we can see in the scoreboard
that even though the two are tied with
peter lecko but i think peter still has
disappointing tournament for peter as
well but there's been some solace in the
quality
of chess that he's played he's had
several armageddons he
has won several games but for wishianan
and dingler and this
has uh been a disaster of an event the
only good news is
that it ends with them today all right
let's take a look at the match-ups for
the day
we've got boris up against yan yan has
confirmed his spot in the semis
so it's going to be an all-out play for
him but that's just yan in every game
semis or not ding laren playing peter
lecko
again um these two are at the bottom of
the of the
of the rankings currently so not a very
important match
in terms of the qualification
vasalavanchuk against vishwanath
a match of two legends yes no chance of
qualification but that match promises to
be very exciting one
the main reason being that vasil has
always shown that regardless of what's
the tournament situation regardless of
what's the math situation
he has indeed always gone for an
extremely
well exciting and combative chess peter
swiddler against aneesh giri a very
important match aneesh
i think for aneesh as well because if he
finishes fourth in case he was to
in case he loses to peter and let's say
peter leap frog zanish
anish finishes fourth he meets magnus
carlsen in the semis
i'm not sure if that's a scenario he's
looking forward to he has to play magnus
at some point
but i think the idea would be to try and
meet him in the finals
uh peter swiddler looking good right now
to qualify but like i said if vlad does
win against magnus in the rapid portion
and peter goes down to a niche
in again in the rapid portion that would
mean peter gets kicked out
vlad comes in so lots of exciting chess
going on today
and uh we are going to have tomorrow
we're going to have a break date before
we resume
back to the semis of course yan and
judith will be joining us
shortly before that a quick reminder
that
you've got you've got what you've got 48
hours
to book your spot for uh for a symbol
against the world champion another big
opportunity
organized by chess 24 the world champion
magnus carlsen will be giving
a similar to to to all of you who either
extend
or buy a two-year membership plan it's
it's a guaranteed spot in the final
and um do it now you have to register
before 31st july
to book that spot the other big hot drop
has been
in our store with uh with these
lovely mugs of uh some very
not so lovely individuals well at least
not so lovely individuals over the board
off the board they're all great and we
not only with the legends but also
there's team millennials so you can pick
whatever you want have a look at our
store some great stuff
uh going on there what else i got for
you
yes my favorite part so i've been
hanging out with you watching all the
chess with yan
sasha and judith but also having some
fun conversations on twitter with you
guys
so let's take a look at what you had to
say about
the event so far all right so we got
kanak saying today is a special day my
two favorite players
gonna play against each other legend
versus legend
legend vs legend indeed and i think this
is what is so special about this
tournament
even though wishy is at the bottom of
this of the table of the ranking
still every time he plays it's it's a
lot of fans his his entire
well all of india pretty much rooting
for him waiting to see him come back
into action and of course watching
vassal is always
is always a pleasure let's move on
we also had texas chess association
lawrence it was great seeing you in
in the chat for chess legends hoping for
a repeat lawrence if you're watching it
you've got to come back uh we need you
here all right let's move
on and we had eric writing in today this
brilliant legend will face magnus
carlsen indeed a big big task ahead of
vlad
it's going to be a bit disappointing if
vlad doesn't make it because
he's also had a phenomenal tournament so
it's basically going to be
so we've got three of the chessable
masters semi-finalists who are already
in
and the fight is between one of these
legends vlad and
peter so um something to rejoice for all
those who've been supporting team legend
because this was
this has been a very very difficult
tournament all right even though he
retired he still
shows his love for chess and did it
terrific yes indeed a terrific
tournament for vlad sofa
played brilliantly uh whether it's peter
or
vladimir kramnik who made who makes it
into the semi-finals
we are in for a thrilling ride all right
next one up and foxy are writing in
in his interview with chess 24 evan
chuck said he doesn't regret that he nev
he never was world champion
because that's still possible what a
game he had yesterday with anish um
and he won that match in a brilliantly
played armageddon
even magnus carlsen was superbly
impressed and it was
it was the first armageddon won by a
legend
over a millennial in this tournament it
was not about flagging that armageddon
you know this has been one of the
arguments that's been up here
uh about the role of the clock over the
quality of chess
that armageddon was pure class by evan
shook
anishikari by going into the armageddon
secured that one point
to seal the deal to qualify for the
semis all right
let's move on grand master jonathan
pistol writing in with at the risk of
sounding overly wishy-washy i have to
convince
confess i really enjoyed
the day's blood of online raph hit chess
jonathan yesterday was just tremendous
chess
i think it was such a treat for us with
the broadcast the commentary
by yan and judith and sasha was
mind-blowing
and the and the games that we got to see
over the board three
world-class armageddons uh fighting
chess
all along and i think jonathan has been
he
jonathan in a previous tweet had
expressed that he's been really enjoying
the overall quality of play but it's
also heartbreaking to see that how
it kind of sometimes tends to get
destroyed
because of the time situation and and
then chess just kind of crumbles
to the pressure of the clock and i
totally feel your pain on that jonathan
and
i think i couldn't agree more yesterday
was all about
the chess was the winner of yesterday's
uh yesterday
all right let's move on and we had
anton and the best background book award
goes to swiddler
great to see yasperford and sora wow
anton i mean firstly like major points
for noticing that book in the background
i don't know how you did it
but we all know that peter's got amazing
taste
incredible taste in uh in literature
in music in in arts really
but not so much in sports i mean he
likes cricket so i'm not i'm not really
sure about his uh
his taste in sports but uh
yes um peter's ex peter is into a lot of
classics and literature this is
something he discussed
great job spotting that book back there
though i would not have noticed it
all right and what else we got
wow there is just so much going on on
twitter and i just feel like
it's it's amazing how much love you guys
have shown for this uh
for this entire broadcast and this event
and the tour
so thank you for that keep that coming
in uh using the hashtag chess legends
also i've been noticing that in some of
the tweets you've tagged me but not use
the hashtag
you don't need to tag me you need to use
the hashtag otherwise i cannot
i i won't be able to find the tweet so
please just keep doing that
but use the hashtag chest legends i am
partha saying
wow magnus wow what an armageddon this
show oh my god what was that armageddon
against jan
i think the whole match was just
sensational it was epic
but that armageddon just shows that the
world champion truly in
every time format he's just on his
a-game i mean he
i'm actually not sure if if they can
make three moves and i'm gonna ask
my producer that right now if premoves
are allowed
but uh i don't think i would doubt that
they are
i mean he made something like 20 moves
in seven seconds
okay i do have confirmation that they
can pre-move in the armageddon so that's
quite interesting
and uh which means that he he was
he played so i don't even know how he
did it and all like like it was pointed
out all that practice that he's been
having in his bullet play
and again some of the world's best it
really paid off because
jan nevamyashi is not an easy guy to
beat
when you're low on the clock playing
playing the armageddon magnus carlsen
probably the only guy who was able to do
that
and let's move on to
kilo romeo and he's saying as rightly
said by judith and alexander
it's just a mouse game that's what chess
legends need to do to win
against modern mice be quick and just as
random as possible getting a touchscreen
um you know what i'm not really sure
about that i think yes definitely when
it comes the rapid games having a 10
second increment and the time format i
think that is definitely i would say
i would say 95 chess class you know it's
only at the very
very end and maybe you know it's you've
got you've got increment there so there
it's just all about chess
yes when it comes to armageddon you have
to look at it
as almost like a new variant like a new
format
born out of out of our situation out of
online the boom of online chess
and out of just everything that's
happening around us
this is an esport now and to be able to
play the armageddon is almost like a new
it requires these
different skills from over the board or
from
normal blitz so it's really a test by
fire
of how quickly you you play but
balancing that out with how well you
play
and i think it's it that balance has
been tilting towards the younger guys
because they're kind of like the
computer generation
but i don't think it's a complete mouse
game armageddon definitely yes
more than the rapid all right what else
we got
what an incredible demonstration of
sorry one second what an incredible
demonstration of bullet skills yes
absolutely carsten i think um
i think this this was just unbelievable
what magnus did in that
armageddon is something that you if you
missed it if anybody missed it
go down and watch that action replay
of all of it um
just one second so yeah so definitely go
and watch that action of
the armageddon that we had let's move on
to the next one the games are about to
kick off
in a bit andre with the games of evan
chuck have been such a joy to watch
yes it doesn't matter if vassal
qualifies or not
he has been pure joy to watch he i think
his creativity
and like i was saying i actually read
this somewhere that it was judith polgar
who said who was asked who are the three
geniuses and her list was literally
avishiana and magnus carlson and rasa
levanchuk and i think we've seen
vassil truly express on the board
the joy that he gets with playing and
all of us somewhere in our hearts have
secretly been rooting for vassal to make
it in this event
makes it or not he's impressed us
tremendously
all right
and the strongest player of
the mid 19th century writing into us he
has taken the twitter world by
storm howard staunton the glory of the
young heroes of the chess field ought
not to make us forget
full of that of veterans how it very
well said
i think the glory of the young heroes is
only born out of what
out of the legacy that's left behind by
these veterans and that is what
the legends of chess tournament is all
about
all right let's move on
even though i'm disappointed that anish
lost i'm glad that at least one legend
won the army
yes we were we were talking about this i
mean this is just
it was amazing even and i think a lot of
people who
even anish supporters and fans wrote to
us saying the exact same thing that just
watched watching vasil evan shook
win that armageddon felt just brilliant
because
uh it's not easy to do what he pulled
off against aneesh who has been playing
just just world-class chess just
absolutely incredible over the board i
think
and this is something that magnus has
had pointed out in his interview
that anish has been improving really
really fast uh
and we saw him come into the finals in
the chessable masters
here he's into the semi-finals uh vassel
brilliant job yesterday in the
armageddon all right let's move on
and i see this another one by jonathan
and in fact just in time because i see
judith has
joined us on the broadcast and
jonathan says fantastic answer from
judith
regarding the mindset and expectation
and their effect
on uh women's chess ceiling and uh
let's keep this tweet on the screen
judith welcome
hi i'm very happy to be here
we not not more happy than we are to
have you here and we cannot wait to get
the action started but judith just
yesterday you shared
something so insightful about how uh
how girls are actually bought up with
the idea that
you know the aim is to become the women
world champion but never to become
the world champion and that kind of puts
a border
it confines them to or builds a ceiling
like jonathan
mentioned and you have been the one to
shatter
that uh to shatter that glass ceiling in
many many ways
and of course you mentioned that that
had a lot to do with your with your
upbringing and how
chess was at home today we're going to
be talking
a lot about that in this show because as
usual i cannot wait to chat with you
perhaps during the breaks
but going into today's round do you
think
that what are the chances and i do see
yan is with us as well so i want to hear
this from yann as well
what do you think are the chances of
vladimir kramnik being able to
leap frog and take the semi-final spot
he's got to beat magnus carlsen
and peter's got to lose to anish what do
you think is that a possibility
first of all i believe that obviously
vladimir is not thinking about
what other factors has to be
happening in order for him to be
qualifying he is
suffered from yesterday's games match
and i think
probably he didn't sleep well but i'm
pretty sure that he's
mentally and in every way he's prepared
and it's really challenging for
him that to play against magnus and
still
give it a shot and he knows exactly how
difficult it is to
beat magnus even if you're in your best
and not to talk about him that he's he's
kind of retired already
but i'm sure that he's going to give all
in
uh not necessarily only because to
qualify but
to show that he's he still has his lying
teeth
i we can't wait for that matchup to
start and we do have liftoff
yan welcome to the show over to you take
the flaw
thanks sonia hi everybody i cannot
wait either although math-wise
it's hard to see anyone really making
these semi-finals that is not called
carlson nepam nishi
geary or swiddler you did i think
that vladimir kramnik would have to win
in the regular rapid portion against
magnus
and svidler would have to lose in the
regular rapid portion
for kramnik to overtake swiddler it's
going to be tough right
well absolutely i think vladimir will
focus on his games and it would be a
great
great accomplishment if he could could
win the four game mini match against
magnus i don't think he would mind too
much not qualifying if you can
make the victory in this match yeah also
one thing we know about magnus even if
he's already locked into first
he's not going to be giving away any
points
to vladimir he always wants to win at
everything
absolutely and it's in some ways it's
even easier to play right when
you want to ready the event and you
qualified but
it is it is one of the trademarks i
think of top players
that usually you see even though they
they make a very high score and
they are in the lead and nobody can
catch them even then they
they go for it and they want to win i
experienced this also once against
kasparov and in vacancy he won already
the tournament
he had a point and a half ahead and
still in the last round we had the tough
game
any other matchups you're looking
forward to today
even chicano maybe uh that
that is a kind of nice retro match right
it's like first time i think they've
played maybe 30 years ago maybe 35
i think they played in the junior in
world championshiping back in 89 so they
were
both i think similar age groups
yeah must have been a while like at the
very least around
1991 they were both
already breaking into the very top okay
later
so what do we see here
in this game
what do we have it's the ragozin
very fashionable opening nowadays played
regularly by vishy
but evan chuck as usual likes to go his
own way
a little bit and plays the move a3 here
not what they usually do they usually
either take or go bishop g5
or queen a4 bin a4 queen b3 i was
playing this with the black pieces
a short time yeah
it's a very very trendy opening we've
seen
for example magnus carlsen over the
course of these last events try
literally
every move against this queen a4 cd
bishop f4 bishop g5
yeah one funny game where he played
bishop g5 h6 bishop d2
short castles and g4 yeah yeah
and i was seeing this again i thought i
mean
it's quite impressive
i'm not sure is it for classical game do
you think
first of all i don't think black is
forced to castle after this bishop g5 h6
bishop d2 like any move knight bd7 or c5
yeah
and i'm not sure g4 works but it was fun
to see
while it lasted eventually though he
plays this move a3
sort of saying this is a bluff you don't
really want to give me your bishop
and this she takes on c4 i guess c5 is
an option to
point to e3 very greedy queen d5 he just
wants to keep his pawn
do you like that move well it's clear
that he wants to keep the
the phone and b5 was probably not the
move he would be looking forward because
a4 and bishop a3
and after c6 bishop a3 this is what he
wanted to avoid i guess
well after the game move queen d5 knight
d2
yeah looks very logical or uh also
possible maybe what do you think about
a4 immediately
yeah i was wondering same idea bishop a3
so black has to castle
and after that knight d2 i start with
this yet
or knight e5 optionally not sure
though still bishop c4 is not possible
because the g2 pawn is hanging
maybe some quiet move like b6 but then
i don't know then bishop b2 looks very
strong
yeah too complicated already yeah this
would give some trouble for black
let's see what evancho comes up with but
once again he's managed to give
us a fairly non-standard position after
seven moves he's
he's got this gift to play normal
looking moves but still
not quite the main line so it's always
something we've never seen before
knight d2 let's play b5 ah but after b5
bishop e2
you have to go c6 a4
seems to be very very dangerous it takes
p5 and you cannot take with the phone
back
so what's your probably after 92 just
castles right
or c5 eventually
so if uh knight c4 black goes b6
but even now bishop e2 can be difficult
but now bishop to bishop a6 i'm sure a6
is better
and as we know exchange sacrifices
always happen here even c6 first
possible this looks horrible this would
be
paradise for black unlikely to
be true let's have a look around
what's happening in our two key matches
magnus carlsen with the white pieces
he's playing this
what do you call this joko pianissimo
the slow italian
you must have done this quite a bit no
yeah it's gonna be a long game
and the better wins yeah
nowadays a lot of people prefer this
move a4 to the more
classical they should be three keeping
this option to grab some space with b4
and a5
magnus has of course done this with both
colors
knight to f1 rook to e8 it's always this
little debate if
white
sorry to play h3 or not to play h3 yet
right yeah yeah if you can do without it
if there's a more useful move but it's
never so clear because a3 is quite
quite decent but i believe magnus might
have played something like b4 in a
similar position
in the past trying to do without it but
actually yeah
yeah it's a question whether he wants to
go b4 or or maybe knight g3 and to
possibly play d4 but i'm not sure
yeah this is a typical thing does knight
g3 black plays which should be six
takes d4 and it's always a question if
d5
equalizes move by move or if white can
ask a question here
i believe usually white is playing for
something very small advantage now it's
more
of having a middle game and somehow
magnus has all the self-confidence that
he will simply outplay the opponent
right
i've been surprised frankly that this
italian these very slow setups
they've been so fashionable for three
four years now at the highest levels
i always thought at some point black
will have figured out the precise move
order
and will just be equal but they just
keep coming and coming
yes but if you think about it the these
systems became fashionable because there
are so much theory in the concrete lines
in the rye lopez or
other things yeah it's kramnik's fault
okay not to talk about the berlin
yeah especially if you play against
vladimir there is
a great chance that you end up having
this position on the board after
move three yeah you mentioned yesterday
that he made you
and kasparov as well quit the king's
indian
now he's made everybody quit the rui
lopez as well he's just
destroying openings yeah i don't think
that in 2000 when he was playing this
system worked out against kasparov that
he thought that he's going to be
paralyzing the whole chess elite playing
three bishop b5
yeah but actually it's happening right
he's had such an influence all joking
aside not just the berlin not just the
king's indian
but also with white we see the catalan
is still very much on vogue that's what
he brought
to the table the petrov was still used
by karana in the last world championship
match
so he's had a tremendous imprint on
very modern top level yes
peter how's peter swiddler doing
this line i don't know very well g3 c6
knight f3 it's like some reversed
alapino what do you call this
okay i think
usually they play knight c2 here but
e3 we've also seen i don't know very
much
well e3 is logical right max move knight
c3
bishop c5 knight c3
d5 keeping protected the e4 pawn
pawn to d3 takes queen takes
okay so why developed black is
kind of fine
looks okay for black no like long term
maybe white could hope to get these
pawns rolling but with all this pressure
on the center
hard to see that happening yeah knight
e2 happened
right we should be six
queen c now c five is a threat
queen c two and i guess whites two
one to play b3 bishop b2 or bishop d2
bishop c3
yeah what should black do well
the question is how is he going to
develop with his bishop on c8
right is he going to go to g4
and develop or he's going to move it his
knight first
i was gonna suggest queen h5 bishop h3
but then i realized knight f4 that would
not be
a very bright idea so yeah i don't know
maybe knight a6 to leave options open
i guess i would go bishop d2
actually it looks nice for what
yeah for the moment it looks not so easy
to
make a harmony between black species
it seems like for white he is
he has the pieces in the more or less in
the right
place
peter remember all you need is one point
if you make it
to the armageddon you're good
i don't think the players will do this
but there was this famous
football match some time ago germany
austria
where they would both qualify if they
made a zero zero
do these things happen in chess you
think they could make four draws
some more modification is needed right
and there's added incentive as we're
being told
that if peter wins this match he also
avoids magnus in the semi-finals
which i guess is something well that's
also attempting target
right something to achieve that
not sure but anyway i don't think he's
thinking too much of of that four games
is too much
to to make all kind of tactics like that
also it's tough for the commentators to
speculate about no they these guys are
just thinking about
well what move to play so knight a6 is
in the boar
on the board i know my anish
yeah it's logical that black wants to
keep the option for the bishop to
develop to
d7 or g4 but definitely somewhere
for now b3 is not possible due to c5 is
that correct
i think so
no bishop d2 looked very normal stopping
knight before
heading maybe black might be going
knight c5
aiming to play knight e4
to centralize and
bishop c3
white is threatening knight c6
and maybe
maybe black just goes back when e7
somehow i want to keep the my eye on the
e4 square be sure b4 is interesting but
then i go a5
bishop a3 and probably back to e5 with
the queen
you've tricked my bishop into oblivion
yeah you
your bishop and now you can play
actually b3 finally yeah that's true
little dancing with the bishop right
we'll see the guys are that creative
let's look at some nice classical
central chess
boris girlfriend
some good old grunfeld
boris must have been annoyed to see that
game yesterday where magnus worn against
him from the
with his system from the 90s yes
because boris has switched to this more
modern setup
or these days fashionable setup of
course it's old as well
some theory debate
this is one night right variation i was
playing that
and karpov
matches you remember yeah i was gonna
ask in 1987 you you were following
probably already
yeah yeah i was following with my sister
sophia very
and my sister susan also how did you get
the moves
back then that was before internet of
course
of course but on television we had the
summary
and uh even on the russian soviet
television we could follow it
live so that was really exciting
no seville variation this time the
partnership plays bishop d7
this is also what svidler recommended in
his video series
he was explaining to me there was some
smart reason why you provoke
f3 some lined as bishop it's important
that it's
undefended but i can't recall where i
think some queen a5 and some queen a3
was hitting it somewhere
well white seems to have a very strong
center
it's kind of tempting to play it from
the right side to me
black has not been able to break it he's
trying with b5
i don't understand these positions they
always look bad for black
sometimes the center crumbles
yeah now white has to
maybe after that bishop b5 can be very
strong
boris takes i guess bishop
what about playing a4 is that great it's
crazy yeah
no which position
b5 queen
d2 probably bishop
e2 takes and c4 is not possible due to
bishop b6
though maybe queen f4 bishop d8
bishop d4 king h1 rook d8
queen c4 rook c4 bishop e5 g3
well some compensation but uh
still it's an exchange right yeah
king is not too bad no i'm going to
treat 2. yeah
can black just try to give this pawn and
open the position somehow some e6
i'd be taking on c5 with the rook i
guess
i was afraid so the rook can
i should leave the pawn sacrifices to
you like i have no idea how to follow up
i'm just worried
well i guess rook takes c8 rook takes c8
and
what about knight d4
ed just e5 m well that's one of the
tempting moves but
also knight takes b5 and queen d5 i
would be
thinking of still pawn up
well pawn is a pawn and there is another
one hanging
all right maybe we should what about
bishop e2
and queen a7
and my idea is to go bishop d4
but maybe it's over optimistic queen c4
right and then bishop d4 takes takes
queen c8
maybe this recheck we could
make as intermediate move
after queen c8 ah sorry
yeah queen c5 then okay but it's not so
simple or is it is it just winning or
what is that
i don't know i'm scared three queen e3
like this counter planer
yeah maybe king f2 and king
f3 between d4
and f5
yeah it's kind of not so simple but we
have
in the game plate c4
yeah these spawns it's it's always a
question whether is it going to be
vic pawn or is it going to be a queen
pawn
eventually a dangerous postpone
c4 looks a little sad no with this
bishop on b5 some bishop d well bishop
d4 looks uh very tempting to be played
but in such positions maybe e5 now
take
takes take stakes
knight c3
and we hope this bishop on p5 is not
doing much
so what else we can do with black
instead of e5
i was wondering if this works at all but
yeah of course we all want to give
get rid of that pawn so to open up the
bishop diagonal but i think rook c3
something
bishop takes g7 and king g7 right
24 check
rook c8
no actually not rook c8 maybe rook c1
rook bc1 was possible
ah that's nice it can't be taken and it
takes knight takes yeah
yeah yeah and if rook c3
knight c3 rook c8
but still it
still a little loose but it feels like
we're we're fishing
well there are always some counter play
i guess for black but
i'm not sure c3 is is
possible but why did not allow that
knight c3 which is kind of logical to be
honest
to blockade this d4 pawn and have the
b5 bishop which is not very
active and well placed here
looks very beautiful for white it's
about the time to play e5 no
at least it's very tempting d6
queen d5 jack
goes out e6
i don't know i'm not sure d6 is the
right move but it's very tempting
these kind of tactics
so many options here for white knight t5
25
yeah an id5 queen f7 right yeah
well even that is kind of very
unpleasant if he takes f6
takes takes takes and bishop d4
black goes queen f5 probably
yeah somewhere bishop a1 maybe
looks very dangerous well it's kind of
scary yeah
though here probably no
well yeah it's kind of tricky for
for black
well of course d6 is something i think
boris is is calculating but because
after e6
f5 bishop d4
let's say
also looks unpleasant actually
well the b5 bishop is upsetting from
black side i guess
so after all i think knight c3 was a
good choice
very classical too known he's just
blockading just in case and limit the
opportunities and tactical
tricks it's a very
safe move but actually girlfriend is
very much down on time
he has almost half of the time what uh
ian has
it's hard to avoid against nepal she is
so fast no everyone's down on time
he beat magnus carlsen the other day in
game four finishing with
more time than what he started the game
with hit 1505 as sasha pointed out at
the end of the game
all right which game do you want to see
uh let's see how things actually let's
uh take a look how ding is playing
we haven't seen too much of that game
yet
just to take a glance how is what is he
up to
it's also an italian right
it's the new ding playing one e4 playing
all the openings
which i'm sure will be a great thing for
him long term but this tournament
has not gone well he has no well
probably from
already for a few days he's uh aiming to
finish the tournament and forget it
right
yeah no wait unfortunately
we all have such a tournament in our
career
yeah and as sasha also mentioned
yesterday must be incredibly hard to
play with his
internet vpn connection issues if you
never know
if you will get disqualified from the
game
because of a disconnection must be very
hard for him
so i'm sure he'll be back it's not a
nice experience for sure
so the position some isolated pawn
who's better and why
well i guess knight comes to c5 yeah
that's what happened in the next move
at first sight i would rather play it
with white to be honest
i mean white is much more developed
right
here's knight e6 exchanging this bishop
well white is definitely
playing for initiative i guess
that d4 pawn can never be taken
can it let's see
it's hard to believe takes takes bishop
b4
yeah okay so he he could not take it yet
at least
and went back knight d5 right
lego under pressure i have a somewhat
off-topic question for you that's been
debated a lot in the
chat the other days we were discussing
the greatest
hungarian players ever now obviously
your name comes up italico's name comes
up how do you rate
some of these historic figures that i
know nothing about do you know stuff
about
i don't even know marozzi these kind of
people well we had
maruti of course he was the most famous
one but we had bartha for example he was
an excellent
endgame specialist i remember actually
susan was going to him back many years
ago like 35
or something years ago you and i visited
him but he was already very old at that
time
he was very respected of course
we had banco who was also a great
uh not only chess player but also a
fascinating personality
he just passed away last year
and we had diane oban he was also pretty
good
and so we had we had we had a huge
history and of course later on we had
the huge generation of
porte sachs ribley adorian
and even the second
line was pretty strong like
that there were quite a few strong
players like josef horvath
those maybe later john
and and others bilac we had a huge
history and the great tradition
and i always say that in hungarian sport
in general i think chess is definitely
in the top three
uh most successful sports as
we have in the last more than 100 years
always had players in the top ten and
even
almost fighting for for the title
but definitely a top 10 player then
laiko was there of course for
for a long time amashi so we had some
good
pretty good generations and now we have
uh
richie robert who is a top 20 player and
he's a great talent but after that we
don't we we cannot be as proud as
river in the in the last hundred years
but still you you can find
talents not such a talents that you
would expect them to be in the top 10 or
top 20
but still chess is a is a respected
sport in hungary
definitely would you say there's
something like
a hungarian school of chess
and ascent everyone's different when i
think of hungarian players there's this
prototype a bit like laco who are
incredibly well prepared incredibly well
educated
incredibly good in end games very hard
to beat
sometimes you could argue too solid for
their own good and there's many other
such guys but then there are also
players like you and rapport who are
almost the opposite what's what's going
on there
but i think you can find the different
characters different players different
styles in uh
in every country on on a different level
but but indeed we had
unfortunately somehow there was
an image of what what foreigners like to
say that
hungarians is kind of drawing people
except me for some time and
it's in some ways it was true in many
many players they were more solid and
they didn't mind to
to make a draw and even
many of them were kind of famous for
making short draws so they were not
having that fighting spirit and um
and and it's true but uh but not a guy
who wants to make short draws
or even who wants to make draws and
i was of course always a fighter
very strongly i was not aiming for draws
but even later on i had a few
few draws i remember and
um but yeah it's true that
that hungry hungarian players had this
image but if you think about it some of
the great players
even ribley had this image a little bit
later on but he was
a top 10 player for many years but
sucks dula was also very famous top 10
player he was also very very good
he was he was the fighter he was the
tactical
he was someone who was not ready for a
compromise by any means
so he was definitely one of one of the
persons who represented the attacking
chess
and the combinations when i was little
like eight nine
ten years old i remember traveling a few
tournaments with him and it was great to
experience
and analyze some games with them
wow things are happening in the meantime
yeah
alexander grishock has also arrived in
the meantime
welcome what's going on yeah hi
good evening ladies and gentlemen uh so
we have a last round and
also four qualifying spots are
more or less secured still we have a
battle
for third place peter swiddler has to
beat anish and i think it does
i don't know what happens if he wins in
armageddon
but if he wins without then he's
definitely served
and it's important because third place
avoids
magnus in the semi fight
different level of goals right in a
tournament
in this system first to qualify once you
are very close to qualifying
then how how to to avoid magnus in the
next stage
yes yes of course it can be crucial
that's true
how's peter doing is he winning a pawn
peter was pressing yes
more or less the whole game well knight
fd7
knight c8
or b4 i don't know if b4 was possible
move before instead of knight c8 that's
also
something knight d3
bishop takes b6
takes and a3 yeah e3
and if c5 we have bd5 maybe
or bc5
it looks quite stressful for black
yeah definitely
b493 is on the board
yeah i wonder how uh how did magnus
trick
blood image so easily in the opening
he managed to get a theoretical position
without
playing h3 which which in the structure
they got
is completely useless so
he got an extra tape and also he didn't
weaken his skin side
i think maybe vladimir mixed up with the
moon folder because
yeah okay the h6 stops bishop g5 systems
but sometimes you allow white to play
without h3 well if you start with
castles
yeah it's harder because then there's
always this stuff
or you can start with bishop a7 yeah
so it was a strange because then what
they got is the usual position but
white managed to get it without h3
and then yeah everything worked
basically to perfection for magnus
because he
uh he met knight on g6 with g3 and now
it
becomes obvious that h3 is absolutely
useless and
only would weaken the cube side slightly
so and then yeah he played typical
moves and
this idea we've seen quite a bit in this
tournament already in this structure
it's d5 c4 t4 night jumps
actually very nice play by magnus
slowly but surely he's just
with every move he is increasing the
pressure and
advantage that's a nice one what is this
tactics take stakes yeah
takes takes rook c7
what is it knight v6 knight e3
you don't know it's always a check
but vladimir did not take it he won
quincy
h7 does not look good
having some check i guess he will play
rook 88 oh yeah
i don't know or maybe not
or maybe it's maybe it's just maybe
knight g6
just to
step away if you want to check to block
the chip
i don't know how obvious is that now
i'm not so
uh proud of this knight d4 uh
c60 k5 maybe it's good but
it just looked like white was completely
dominating and as
this knight would go to f5 then another
and black played knight g6
actually it is interesting that black is
somehow getting
out of the passive situation
if you might still need to make it back
flow
r8
which move if queen f3 black just goes
rogue d8 right
and the white knights are kind of tied
to each other
but maybe white just goes rook c1
and if queen f3 can i take on a5
ah okay
though
yeah that's still hanging but what about
rook a5 rook d5
then i thought i will take on a foreign
takes takes a4 rook e8
queen c4 oops sorry
that that i didn't mean to give that
away
it's like lebron james blocking iguadola
from behind
reference for four people
okay so after knight g6 white should be
smart
yeah and magnus is taking two minutes to
try to be smart he now
but they went down in time a lot wow
magnesium
and they both have 40 seconds so okay
might be some chances
h4
i don't know what to do now
so he takes i guess
now take steaks uh-huh
and queen a4 yeah so
and magnus starts to sink again so he
didn't
work this one through queen d3
but now knight b6 i guess he would just
want screen
f5 for b1
oh yeah then a queen of queen f5 finn f5
rook d5
oh
knight b6 plate
so again i think something magnus got
confused with something here
but maybe it's still very good for him
maybe it works
kramnik down to seconds took on d1
rook takes h5 as a threat
you go h5 five green f5
h6
h5 plate h6
group d4 what's that about oh that's a g
proof c3
queen d1 maybe
wow
such harmony
but queen d1 king h6
or queen c5 also possible
group d6 what is he doing knight c4
the little engine bar is jumping all
over the place
does not like rook d6
what about knight a4 queen d1 is double
attack
that's the idea c4
queen e5 is a good spot
black is fine no coordinated seems like
and also if he is in time to
like get his queen to e4 and play knight
e5
he might just win so it's double edged
completely double h
rook d7 plate
b6
queen d1 threatening rook d5 maybe
f5 yeah queen f5 is a nice move
making space for his knight actually now
it's dangerous for white
magnus starts bailout operations with
queen d3
yeah the rookies hanging there
so much drama tension is high
you could see you can see on the
player's faces right
one zero with four seconds magnus
maximum
stakes are mediocre but tension is very
high
magnus offering to repeat moves
i don't know how but i think my vladimir
will decline
maybe even by maybe the h5 pawn
or just uh queen e6
but queens
queen f5 draw
okay but you said what happens if
vladimir wins
without armageddon and peter loses no
it's true there is still a chance
like if kramnik wins it in four and
peter losing for
kramnik makes the semifinals so there
are some sticks
okay what happened
did not manage yeah
we missed vichy versus anant
but they also drew
vishy i'm sorry um
and we still have girlfriend upon
she ending lyran okay so it's completely
winning
took some pawns
doctor ding is also winning
f6 can't you go just
neither four
doing calculating this i learned the
rule of the square there
ah oh my god
this is too much sorry no
f6 seems to be better
looks good now what are you doing no
it's six i don't know
if there is always even knight f6 uh
i mean then this one is probably winning
but sometimes
such positions are wrong
well this is a drone or b4
no but you could go h4 before i think
ah yeah it's four and then four here and
then you take a knight g3
no and the importance that before you
play knight g5 check
no no not g5
no knight h5 maybe also
but they have this position isn't this a
draw king h4
maybe not because the night from dc will
be very fast
yeah to mate yeah it's like a
perfect spot
let's see if they played out the king
will go to h8
and then you have to be careful with
white
but it's gonna be good yeah king goes to
g6 and knight id5
in the chat he's saying knight c6 takes
a5 looked totally wrong by carlson
kramnik wasn't troubled before that was
a sitting duck before
yeah it was interesting actually that i
would take it
but maybe magnus underestimated queen c7
no
i'm not sure he was calculating it all
the way
i mean then it was
i mean after knight g6 black suddenly
had a great display
so round number one has concluded
we have jannie pomneshi beating
boris girlfriend with the black pieces
and he didn't have a good position
yeah that it's shaky
you had a terrible one yeah and
apparently margo's game
instead of knight c6 knight f5 is plus
four i just looked
ding wins against lekko
draw as mentioned
we will bring in tanya
and i think yuri will stay around for
more questioning
and update on social media see you guys
for the next one thank you
yan indeed an incredible round and good
to see that vlad has recovered from his
loss yesterday it's very important to
keep the momentum
and uh he had a difficult start in
today's game but the fact that he was
able to neutralize that and in the end
even have some advantage i think it's a
it's a big confidence boost um to be
able to hold the first
game because as we all know that
vladimir kramnik indeed
needs to win this match in the rapid
portion
to have any shot at qualifying for this
semis
uh we do have judith with us for this
break so of course we're going to make
most of it
lots of questions coming in from all of
you for
judith judy thank you for staying with
us uh
before we start with the questions just
your your thoughts about
about the first round uh
well this was very exciting with the
magnus game against vladimir as
magnus really outplayed the vladimir
from
starting move 1617
up to knight c6 which is what 27 so in
those 10 moves
he was really pressing from move to move
and exemplary
and then it's it was so interesting that
knight c6 which uh
we thought at first that it might be
killing
actually it won a pawn but gave conte
chances for vladimir which he took
immediately
this opportunity here knight c6 and
it seems like it was over optimistic
because after queen c7 knight a5
somehow the two knights of magnus was
misplayed and the pawn was not
so important anymore in this position
and then i think
magnus is kind of happy that he saved
the game at the end because
it was very dangerous already that
vladimir will win the game but he could
not make it
that one but it was a nice save by
vladimir
so that that was a a nice game i thought
that
ian had difficulties after the opening
it was very tempting for white but then
we could not follow because we were
following the
magnus's game but it was very very
dangerous very
unpleasant around the move after f6 move
23
this is where we stopped analyzing it
and we discussed it what happened in the
game d6
but generally speaking black's bishops
are
not so exemplary powerful as
you would expect from bishop pearce uh
but i think here it was very dangerous
but we know that ian is a kind of player
that who has
in many occasions or quite a few
occasions dangerous position
uh shaky things
uh yeah here well black is opponent up
right
right so yeah clear that he was waiting
for
the playing for a win so generally ian
is always someone who no matter how
dangerous position he is in he's going
to be kicking and he's going to come up
with interesting creative ideas
and will give a difficult time for the
opponent and of course the time
factor is always part of it especially
in these rapid
games sorry uh you know
i think this was a very interesting uh
ending that we had and i want to show
our viewers
how it's really lost for black because
you and yan
showed this incredible idea but it
didn't happen in the game
uh that white is just in time
with the with meeting black can you take
us through why this is winning for white
yeah if let's say black is just doing
nothing but pl
yeah like this king f5 let's say not
king e6 blundering the pawn but going
king g6
then white will be going king g4 king h6
h5
you go back king g5 king g7h6
king g6 and then after here you can go
h7
or knight e5 first doesn't matter h7
king h8
and then knight e5 b2 knight f7
checkmate
so this is really interesting also
because uh
this is pretty much the last square that
the knight has to block the b
pawn in case the pawn is on b2 and the
knight is defending it from d2 it's just
not in time
yes then it would be draw but actually
he had many different ways also to win
the game
it was only the way probably not the
simplest and
there were simpler ways but uh it seemed
like what we've seen out of the game
that it was kind of a balanced game
binding
i mean when he had the bishop pair in
the middle game it was clear that he's
the one who is pressing
right um here it was exchanged already
but here the rook is on the seventh
which is extremely powerful right an
all-out convincing game by ding no in in
this
in this round it's a pity that ding is
he won yesterday and this uh he played
really well today as well but it is a
bit late for
the chinese superstar to make a run for
the semi-final spot
now uh judith you know this event of
course one of the big themes in this
event
is the whole how multi-generational it
is and you've got the legends
of the previous generation playing
against well the legends of
today uh we received a very very
interesting video judith of
yours when you were when you were just
13 years old let's try and have that
video play
first and
you know it's just incredible to see
that with the demonstration board at the
back
being handled uh you know
manually and now here we are with 2d
chess being played by
these multi-generational participants
and thank you for sending that here
again and judith the question is
do you remember this game and what was
your experience in a setting like this
yeah it was kind of funny to see this
video uh
if i'm right this was played in the tv
studio in cologne
probably it was 89 if i remember well
and i'm not sure maybe it was a draw
and i could qualify this way for the
year after because it was a yearly show
and it was a rapid game and black
passes on uh to the next year's tv show
i think
but and the year after i played against
knock
where i played a very spectacular game
that i remember better
but actually we were playing in a in a
glass
cage button button like that
and there was an audience outside who
was listening
uh helmut flager in the german
television
so it was live event of course it
looks kind of funny uh from nowadays to
see this classic
demonstration board but it was a live
event actually
you know judith it's like amazing to see
this with you
and how with you right now and just
how warm your personality is and how
much you're you're you know
you can see the happiness and the joy
while talking about chess and then we
see this 13 year old judith who looks
extremely ferocious you had already made
a grandmaster norm by then no
actually i think this was still before
because i made the grand master norm in
the
summer of july or august in amsterdam
and i think this was somewhere in the
spring this event
so i was already quite strong i had my
rating 25
55 or something like that so it was
created
eric had to take me seriously there but
i think only a little bit later a few
months later i made my first
gm norm your first gm norm when you were
13
a grand master when you were 15 and uh
the only woman in in the history of
chess to have
entered the world top 10 um
it just incredible achievements and it
keeps bringing me back to what we were
discussing earlier judith about you
being the only one to have been do
to have done that to have been in the
world top 10 to have qualified in the
world championship cycle
to have played it um breaking just all
gender barriers you are that example who
has
motivated an entire generation and you
often credited
your upbringing and your parents for
what you have achieved
and i i want to ask you a little bit
about this judith
your father was an educational
psychologist and
this age-old debate of you know nature
versus nurture are you born with it or
or do you become it can can a
world-class player be made or is talent
everything and uh i think your father
always wanted to prove that geniuses are
not born but made
now when you look back at it how do you
how do you see that how
do you do you also believe in that
just i don't know share your insights
about this whole nature versus nurture
debate and the experience the firsthand
experience that you had with it
it's a question which i get
pretty regularly and i get questions on
email
and and everywhere it's always a
question and the debate i think and
everybody is looking
at at it from their own perspective
on experience for me the way i was
growing up i was already number three in
the family my
both of my sisters played chess by the
time i started to play chess
and it was something very natural to
grow up this way not to go to school
being home schooled and focusing on
chess
and it was something
er talent i think is important
but without work and dedication and
perseverance and passion towards what
you're doing
it's most of the time it goes to waste
of course there are some exceptions
where where talent
even if they don't get the the most
perfect fit for their training and the
opportunities they can still be very
exceptional players
but for to be much much higher
if they would have a structured planned
schedule and i never thought that i'm a
genius or anything like that i thought
of course quality matters a lot how you
train and what you train and
but also quantity matters to be honest
so
my visual tactical visual on the
chessboard i'm quite convinced that
i have it because i was spending so many
thousands of hours
solving tactical puzzles or studies or
all kinds of tactical themes and
this made me possible to do the things
what i was doing on the chess board and
of course when
you're successful in those things uh
you're
even more want to do the same thing and
you go on that direction
so talent is important but
without the the dedication and hard work
and opportunities to get
then i think it's usually it's 99
it goes to waste and it can be also very
bitter feeling for some talent i know
that
some talents believe oh i will do things
by
being a talent and being talented but
but then you feel the frustration that
you could have such a big opportunities
and you were not
putting in the the hours and
the hard work into that yeah wow
um yeah definitely like they say that
talent gets you only so far but
magic happens when talent is combined
with hard work
judy you know now whenever there's a
super tournament an elite tournament
you've got these
uh you've got these top 10 players and
we see them play against each other
constantly when you were in the world
top 10 when you were one of
the best players in the world uh you
were also playing in this sort of an
elite group playing these close
tournaments
with these best players in the world uh
fighting it out for the top places
winning so many super tournaments i want
to know because we haven't seen that in
our time
what was that feeling like was it did
was there a lot of
extra attention because you were a woman
player a lot of publicity around that
factor did that come in or was the focus
only on the strength of play
of course i was looked at with strange
eyes when i got into the top level
competitions which was i started to play
against the
top grand masters let's say top 30 top
40.
when i was about 16
17 that then already i was playing on
on those tournaments uh it took time
until they got used to me because
it was kind of strange being the only
girl and then later
a woman i grew up and
and also even some people said that okay
you're talented
and you're so special when you're kid
but watch out that
when you grow up and your adult you have
to prove it not only being good for your
age but you have to be good
for your profession and
well i took the challenges but then
later on i remember one of the
nicest compliments i think i was
receiving from vichy
later around 2000 or something that in
an interview she was telling that she's
one of us
when the journalist was trying to figure
out that where is my place in the
in the chess elite so they they got used
to me after a while and they were
accepting that i'm one of them which was
a great feeling that i was working for
for many years but also i had some funny
stories like
when i was playing in linares i think it
was still
2001. or maybe it was before maybe it
was 97
when uh obviously most of the guys
they're used to it
when they go to a tournament and the
bathrooms are separated for the chess
player so the audience cannot be going
to those bathrooms and
so the guys when they play in a
tournament if there is not enough
bathroom for the guys they just enter
into the ladies right
and then one of these occasions i found
myself
by going into the bathroom and suddenly
gary was standing in front of me
so it was it was kind of there were some
funny scenes like that
and but eventually
everybody knew who has to go to which
which one
uh so i mean
it was kind of interesting and also
strange that i was playing
in many tournaments there especially
there were events in spain they had many
many events there
and it happened that out of the 10
players maybe in another tournament
also vr four or five or six players are
the same
so it's always uh this isn't always an
issue i think generally speaking
but uh for example i think it was uh
very nice that
i think magnus was the person the the
first world champion
for a long time or maybe ever i don't
know exactly
who started to play in open tournaments
and
giving the opportunity to to be with him
in one room and to
other players who are not on the top
level to see him play
and uh while i was not playing really on
open events
and not really the top players were
playing in open events because in those
times
the top players were expecting
invitations
and mostly or almost hundred percent we
were playing a round robin event
which means that you can prepare and you
can be focused and you have your mindset
already
that you're going to play exactly
against those players
and nowadays it's interesting when
magnus or other top players like isle of
man
or some event you have like
really lots of great players and even
the top players are playing
but i think this is always an issue in
the in
for every generation that from
organizers point of view
they want to have the best players right
and
even if they cannot get all of them they
get
some of them and then some some of the
players are playing always on the
top tournaments i love it i can even
imagine
uh i mean i i can't imagine the feeling
uh
you know like you mentioned that it was
a special moment when vishyanan said
that she's one of us
because a lot of times what happens is
that you know it's always like she's an
extremely strong
woman player but to have that validation
from your colleagues from
from your competitors it it does feel
like you've crossed
that boundary and now it comes to your
strength of play and also judith
very nice point about yes magnus playing
in open events and now
all these strong grand masters playing
in uh
in in a lot of these events which are
happening
i think one of the reasons for that is
that the general conditions have
improved as well
for open events and the prize money has
improved
the organization has improved from your
perspective as
having been one of the world's best
players and now from a spectator point
of view
what's more exciting to watch an elite
event where
you know you've got a group of guys
playing against each other or the
uncertainty and unpredictability of an
open
uh well now with the online
life i think it's absolutely the top
guys is the greatest entertainment
but it's not only the games but also the
circumstances
which is possible to follow on the top
left
platforms also here of course chess 24
it's uh it's already you you get an
entertainment you get lots of
information and background stories and
interviews with the players
so those things i think can be very
exciting for the viewers
and but of course there are some great
players who are not necessarily the top
10 players and they can be also very
interesting their games can be
interesting
and also some interesting personality as
well
but i think it's very important when
there is an event going on
whether there is a 26 50 player or 2700
or
2800 to to see the depths
and then and the nice ideas behind it
and if there is a good coverage about it
i think it can be the same entertaining
right agree we can't wait for over the
both chess and open events and classical
events to take off but for
now we've got our second game of the day
taking off
so i am going to pass it on to yan and
judith and sasha hopefully to blow our
mind with some more chess
i'll see you in a bit see you
thanks tanya and i'm not sure if it's
mind-blowing
but yeah 2a3
yeah i was wondering if they are just
making jadoops and it's a mistake but
actually it's online right so it can be
only a mouse sleep but
video you never know
unlikely mouse slip unless you want to
a4 or maybe two knight a3 which people
also play
but no i think someone even wrote a book
about this 2a3 no
like it had some point
don't ask me what i was never
considering here a3 to tell you the
truth
no no this continues g6 bishop c4
the bishop or has a great square on f2
i was hoping for b4 bishop g7
c3 but apparently not
yam is really well g6 was a
prophylactical move
okay h4 of course
well this is completely the last 10
decades of chess
no i mean it it is really developed in
the
in the last 10 years i mean this would
be impossible
to see something similar to this
10 15 years ago isn't it yeah i would
say this is either
like 150 years ago or in the last
five years in between people didn't do
this
yeah that sounds fair enough
h4 we have zasha coming back who will
explain
that this is well i think ian wants to
confuse boris's preparation which he
probably did
i see alexander's smile seeing the
diagram position
yeah it's always not so bad but uh
never so good i mean
i think you always knight f6 is a good
first of all h4h5
this inclusion doesn't really favor
right but
uh knight f6 is always good you fight
night h5
it's like you know very greatly improved
uh
version of yeah of mod yeah
and this is even this is not completely
bad for black but
allocate this before it was magnus who
played it once i think 2014 olympia
he plays it in blitz all the time he
likes to he wants to have it called the
norwegian rhett this knight of six e5
nigeria i see
he played against adams but it didn't go
so well but why
why does he want to it to be called
red i mean red is not the most pleasant
animal i know maybe he feels differently
okay e6 plate and knight c3
h5 d5 you don't want it
so is boris going to play h5 eventually
or no
i don't know
no but actually now it's a very
reasonable line because
the line exists like first move c4 e5
uh g is g3 let's say knight c6
bishop g2 knight c5
knight c3 d6
e3 h5 and it's actually
absolutely normal line it has been
played by
vc and many other strong players
or maybe it's a6 knight g2 h5 yeah maybe
it's
a six and a g two h i think the trick is
they wait for 92 yeah that's why yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah
oh yeah yeah yeah you're all right uh so
a6 knight g2 h5 so now
white got this position so he has a
tempo up
because he's white and
so yeah now as i would say his position
is quite promising
very
let's look at it looks completely fine
for black now
doesn't seem to be dangerous
okay let's see something else
kramnik carlson what's going on here
kramnik sticks to one e4
this line i know but usually they play
queen d3 here no
or is that am i mixing something up yeah
they used to play
it was a big line but i think black
managed to defuse it completely with
some timely queen b6
so this one is some new approach by
redeemer but let's see what's
actually the point of this
by the way the news that magnus plays
night or i'm sure he's done it but not
so often no no actually for quite some
time he was playing it but then he
stopped again i mean okay he was playing
it when he was
working with gary then he stopped for
many years and
recently he started to play it again and
then he stopped again so
yeah it seems like
i mean i'm pretty sure
about what he doesn't like
you can tell us we won't tell anybody no
but basically the lines
that require phenomenal memory yes
quite obvious
all right so what is this equal
it's a quite unusual way of playing with
bishop g4 and exchanging the bishop
there
i don't know maybe some indian computers
they like it
yet for me it looks very strange
especially
night on this real coil lacks
perspectives
yeah it's not going to be too dangerous
seems like somehow black has a great
game no black ghost queen e8
pin f7 rook f8 no maybe okay let's
let's play rook d3 i guess yeah
so and then my point was that if you
play queen c7 i wanted to play rook g3
and just uh hustle there okay there's
nothing special still but i mean the
point was rook g6
queen h3 that was my main point
uh and if rook h6 i take on h6 probably
that was my main idea
even i mean after queen of c you
probably can go rook f6 and i don't have
anything better than repeating but at
least
i can repeat and e from d3 you go to e8
or f8 maybe i can hustle with some
knight a5 i don't know
although there is no c5 i don't know
knight c5
gc now so um no just because
okay i mean it's not like white has some
kind of
plan or piece setup so i think he just
should try to
attack some pawns
to avoid but actually after rook d3
black can start with rook g6
yeah and then actually right should be
going back with his queen probably to e2
and now black goes queen c7
so vladimir has something else in mind
let's have a look at the other games
yeah
giri versus swiddler the other match
that could still be relevant for the
final
four um
good old grundfeld debate switler
decides not to go queen a5 here exchange
queens but place knight c6
f5
is this the line where they used to play
queen a4 queen a5 queen b3
i think so and all those games magnus
against me
uh
always well prepared plays a3
well he wants to go to c1 the phone is
not hanging
and i need to take a kindergarten break
so
hopefully vladimir's idea was not a
kindergarten one and it was very serious
so stay tuned
i don't know what about knight a5
i don't know it looks like peter ran
into some preparation he spent
eight minutes or he said eight minutes
left
while anish still has 16. 95 oh no queen
a4 maybe
yeah and knight b3 is not possible due
to
bishop c4 or no because rook c4 and
bishop d3 is possible after that
or b5 b5 even better
yeah but maybe i can just be boring and
take on c8 and a7 here
maybe knight c1
always troubles with you bishop d1 okay
white has a phone upright
and if bishop d3 then rookie one
that's just the pawn up it seems
no it's not so clear maybe bishop a6
and knight d3 threats yeah
let's see what happened um he played
and bishop d3
isn't knight d4 possible here
no because e takes d4 and after rook c1
bishop c1
okay yes
can we take a pawn
bishop takes and rook c5
and e6 is not possible because bishop d6
i think and rook c6 next
white winds looks unpleasant no also
coin b1
or whatever
yeah this looks like uh interesting
idea so bishop d7 was played
still black is aiming to capture the a3
pawn
so greedy for c3 we can take here
yeah yes
it seems so rook c8 knight f3 and
bishop c8
yeah this would be very nice for black
probably anish will spot that if he
wants to keep his pawn he can play
but i think anishi is ready to give up
his spawn that's
he had to start thinking probably at
bishop d7 first time is to start taking
time
he looks very focused
yeah it's a question how is he going to
move on what about rook b1
probably knight a5 but then the e5
square
is uh gonna be on plus and knight e5 for
example
because i think if after rook v1 you
would be going b6
then bishop a6 is unpleasant yeah
and then d5 or um rook doesn't have any
good scores yeah
yeah that can be unpleasant there
i was wondering if you can just take it
takes root b7
it's also not great maybe it's not the
end of the world but what should be
better
what about just a h3 i know it's three
takes and the d3 bishop is hanging sorry
about that
no then no that was not my plan to have
this ruined bone structure
yeah i know i guess we should be four or
something maybe
maybe it's not much
all right anish will figure it out
let's do a quick tour how nepo is doing
they have some i don't know funny middle
game i must say
okay
it should be one and d very straight
strange
beast set up for white look at the
two passive bishops
isn't black just better
i mean i think after bishop e6 is also
better for black man
yeah castles should we say castles yeah
good enough
it looks very nice
looks great for boris yeah
okay so what about uh
lake coding not a lot of fireworks yet
um
the typical italian
four knights queen on a6 looks kind of
strange
it's normally standing on c7 d7
somewhere there right yeah there was
this ding line yeah this line ding likes
to play where the queen goes to a7 early
on
i'd like sometimes to go this queen b8
queen a7 in the king's indian
king's indian though
do you clear the way there are all these
things you go for the main line
and then how was it it was
uh bishop e3 bishop g5 which line was
that maybe the other book maybe bishop
g5 somehow
i'll just make up some position
something like h6 and bishop
h4
well just the structure for it right and
then
queen b8 and then sometimes i was just
playing h5
bishop h6 bishop e3 and then i was
controlling i had the game
like this against the share of once
yeah somehow i don't know how already i
exchanged the bishop on f to be like
bishop e3 check and bishop f2 take
stakes and queen b8 or something
queen a7 and very rarely
it worked i think but generally of
course in the kings india you don't aim
for to have your queen on this
generally queen on the rim is not great
but now he wants to take on e4 and
knight d3 between d3 or queen c4
queen d3 i guess
all right let's call it roughly
how magnus is doing or evanchuk we
haven't seen the chuki
yes and
this was long siri on knight b7
i never liked that move it exists there
are some games yeah but eventually it
comes to e6 right
and still he wants to go c5
yeah now the question is how to continue
with white
playing e5
knight h5 i guess
yeah g3
double-edged
i never understand is f5 a deep move
here or am i asking i think i would
capture an f6
and id knight e2
yeah open up play knight d4 next
rook c1 put pressure on c6
well the other way is to take not to
play e5 earlier
but to take on d5
probably knight takes d5 takes takes
with the pawn and then
queen a7 check and d4 or in some way or
another to play d4
more queen a7s
and vicious plate option three is gonna
make e2
oh maybe clever
but okay you go d takes e4 bishop f6
queen d1 and then okay
but it's no big deal right the a3 pawn
is just as weak as the c6
here isn't black just fine i can also go
after knight g5 grabs the phone
no yeah knight d4
possibly yeah it feels like it should
enter peacefully somehow
i'm not sure actually about knight g5
maybe rk7
what do you think
it's probably better because i just
don't want to let
white's knight to be very active and if
after rook d3
maybe rook a4 trying to attack on b4 or
b3 c5
and if knight c3 you could have knight
rook b4
or d4 yeah quite a few moves which is
unpleasant
yeah it's not a nice move now before
my money is still on a draw and all this
stuff eventually
actually that's where they are heading
to actually black did not take on d1
interesting why he keeps the tension
after fe4 what does he want to do
play queen a7 queen e3 possibly
i'm not sure fe plate
which is provoking black to go
out of the queen exchange
i'm sure i will take house mr magnus
so who is better and why here
i would say black is not worse if better
i don't know
yeah it doesn't seem so black has
optimal position for his pieces
only the d7 knight could be improved
to c4 let's say
so maybe black can go bishop a7 and
knight b6
magnus goes his own way he does not f6
yeah logical
well it's not that he has any threat yet
but the d2 knight is tied down now
do you think magnus plays for a win here
i don't know he would probably say he
just plays i don't think he would
accept the draw but um that just
will uh vladimir play f3 eventually
though i don't know where my knight will
be going
from d2 even though that now i don't
have to be protecting the e4 anymore
it seems like i have not enough squares
for my knights
yeah somehow i have to say
with the exception of nepam nishi in
this round
the guys could provide a few more
fireworks no
like yesterday with a little more action
today
only this game is fun the others well
but here i see there are some
action non-stop
that is true how is it
so it's one point for the exchange
but it looks pretty good for black
queen d1 only move isn't it yeah let me
just show checkmate because i enjoy it
i don't want that
probably black goes queen b5 grabs
another phone right
this looks really bad for white
and the h6 spawn will have the same
destiny as the
previous ones
just takes the bishop on f4
because this was a great decision i
guess
yeah queen f3 queen d4 no queen
f3 look d4
playing for survival yeah still looks
dangerous e8 and white goes d6 i guess
right
you're saying there's no mate
no but after dc queen h1 can be
unpleasant
so king d2 queen c1 is possible
this looks dangerous for white quite a
bit
no so if queen h1 king e2
f3
king e3
q86 king f3
threatening checkmate ah okay
oops then okay it is not possible then
black has to go queen h1 and queen h6
which after white goes d6 d7
yeah all this on the board
queen g7
queen g7 is i think it's a very strong
move
yeah okay but this should be lost for
white isn't it
king d3
maybe king f6
king e4 king e6 king f4 of d8
this looks bad
two pawns here this game over
maybe after queen g7 he wants to start
with
i know king d3 does something
not too thrilled either rook d8
no it's not great is it
blacklight look d8 immediately
okay but this way i thinking c2
he wanted queen g7 so he can't avoid the
queen exchange so easily right
well queen b4 was possible but
but somehow i think it's important to
control the long diagonal for black
i mean once he has his queen on that
diagonal he goes rook d8 queen i put to
f6
and then start pushing bones
or queen e5 but okay let's see how
napo is escaping here because right now
i'm going to make
d7
ah queen f6
it can be even more unpleasant
queen of eight than king c2 f8 king c2
and after rook d7 i can grab the pawn on
f4
uh yeah after peanut f18 c2 group d7
yeah the problem is still fighting
well he's one of the biggest fighters
here
so fast what's peter doing how is that
going
speeder's suffering and he was trying
but
it would be surprising if he could be
win this game
i guess though the bishop on h6 is very
unpleasant we have to admit that
you maybe
i went the d5 i would have gone to
maybe to a8 but maybe he wants to go to
regroup it to e6
i thought he is possibly afraid of some
rook c1
that's true so that's why he wants to
regroup it to e6 yeah then maybe it can
be dangerous
looks pretty bad now special e6 even if
white just keeps the pawn for now
pawn up wicking some chances
rook these three or something
rook h4 bishop g5 let's say it goes back
rook yeah it goes to e4 or
a4 back
and then bishop f6 rook f4
hmm this will be rough for peter anish
can torture him
yeah it seems not so funny for black
this king is so weak on the dark squares
okay actually here even bishop d2 is
possible
because king g7 is not much of a half
for black bishop sees preacher
so if white is really going to be
controlling that diagonal
with the rooks and the past spawn of
course it can be a huge torture
okay so how things develop with kramnik
and magnus
it's heating up so we got
an own exchange the e5 pawn was
exchanged for the f
to pawn
well it's not too promising for white i
don't like the knight on d2
where should we go we take another three
x and knight f3 right
or knight b3 is also possible and knight
d4
after the exchange what about uh
yeah immediately was not possible
this looks at least fine for whitener
i'm not sure yeah
of course it's not too bad
where's the action
but i was expecting to take it back with
the bishop not with the rook
oh sorry um thanks
i would rather keep both rooks i think
for black
and at some point for example after
knight f3 maybe black can go b4
well take stage 6 through b7
if white would be grabbing a few times
somehow e4 b4 b2 pawns can be
very weak
how's the clock situation ah well that's
equal
both close to four minutes
well actually giri will be giving a hard
time for
swiddler i see it's
not going to be fun to play with this
this with black
at least there's no longer a direct
matrix
the rook on a4 is very much out of play
and it will take a lot of time until it
can come back through a7 d7
did you ever play anish in a game over
the board
or was he yes i played in holland in the
jojo vein
i don't know if i pronounce it correctly
but more or less
he was i think 14 or 15 at the time
that was the first event when i met him
he's been around for quite a while as
well he's oops f5
f5 blunder oh no no no no f6 you have
after bishop f5 rook d6 f6
yeah i thought that black
got in trouble but
no
peter fiddler focused
trying to earn his yeah exchange of one
rooks it could help i guess
this happened
what's your point anish why did he give
the pawn or did he
think peter had blunder as well well
rook b5
okay i guess we go back
it'll be six
yeah did he also blunder
could be nothing sometimes like i did or
what
because it's not why i give the ponies
and if takes
takes no but then you have rook a6 or so
whenever bishop c3
ah but hold on what about g4 on rook c8
rook takes e5 bishop c5
g4 rook c5 takes very the
with the bishop
what's the problem and if bishop d4 okay
3 rook f6
king h7 and king j8 and you save
yeah the game saved
peter looking mildly i know what that is
optimistic
do you think gary blunt under the f6
i think he blundered the same trick no
because visually it's what he mentioned
it looks like
yeah you're cashing in but somehow yeah
peter's already preparing his speech for
how lucky he got
in this game
okay let's see what's going on with
vichy i think
they're
rook on b2 stands cool doubling on a2
this looks scary for white
if well for now it's a draw right
after okay 2 rupees will be 7.
perpetual maybe that's what happens
can white play for more g8
ah that's a good try
hoping for some check my triples
but you can go rook d2 with black
rook e2 might be even better to take the
e5 pawn
rook e2
knight f6 rookie 5 knight d5 check
okay
take steaks b3
rook b5 v2 rook v8
barely yeah but
white is winning eventually goes b3
h4 just in case to have a left for the
king on h2
did he really play h6 what is it it's a
mutual
fund and he's also trying to
speak out king g8 king h7
interesting
what happened with the nepo
and girlfriend well they're still
playing
oh there's playing yeah
yeah girl found the pawn up but
she very centralized
can you save this
yeah king g7 is logical so after h4 f5
you cannot be playing
and queen h4 not with check
even there black is better but of course
king g7 is a much better move
i think white is in a huge difficulty
king a3 or what is he planning to play
so after
h4 still uh f5 would be
tried out i guess
or no take screen h4 queen c5
no ah queen a1 check you have also
but queen a1 king b4
i know p on f5 sorry i was wondering i
thought my queen was on e5 for some
reason
this is pretty good now queen c5 but
king a2 and after rook d6 queen h7 chat
but of course this also looks uh
not much wrong for white
i probably should play queen c3
okay so h6 h4
maybe he wants to go queen c8
and after h3 queen h8
so actually it's a it can be a good try
though queen g4
queen h7 king e6 queen g8
no i blundered here i guess no this this
would be bad for one
so black can not allow well qd5 i don't
want to try this
at least this
how did we get here quincy well uh yeah
i love queen h8 for you king g7 is a
must i guess
stop this
is so tricky even when in trouble it's
so hard to beat that guy
he likes to give the opportunity for his
opponent to make mistakes and go wrong
i see that anand and evanchuk agreed to
draw already they simplified the
position
as well peter and ding also
and anish after that's all
uh did he blunder this
f6 idea or why did he go f5 check what
do you think
i guess i guess i don't know you need to
see it with video just by his reaction
no but okay you wouldn't uh i blundered
it too when we were watching it here
and uh but obviously you have a phone up
so you wouldn't give up the phone
he would go rookie five or something i
guess yeah or
yeah i mean obviously he blended yeah no
it was
pretty painful i think for gary not to
play on this for another 40 moves
peter keeps working on his it will
reputation i don't know what happens if
he loses a match
3-0 and kramnik wins 3-0
so let's see how uh kramnik is doing and
actually he's
uh he's a porno what has happened over
there
he's spun up but black and threatened
one and he and he does
and queen f3 is not possible to queen e5
yeah i guess
but okay he can go rook d1 instead
rook g1 could win ah you have some
tricky lines
so he plays queen f3 so what happens
after queen
b3 what is showing us
that's on the board
so king h8 probably and then queen g5
wow all pieces to the center like the
russians
yeah but okay the king on g4 stands just
perfect right
and they are both slow on time so yeah i
guess
it's very hard to maybe if white plays
h5
i can just play h6
yeah i don't believe he will win but
let's see let's see
i'm afraid he will blunder something
because there is also queen f1 check
which actually i implanted i think here
we should go kg4
but even then queen f1 queen f1
okay e5 is a practical choice okay
justin
after queen e5 just in the row
no he doesn't have a trick
a queen f1 plate
maybe
more tricksy
i know he wants to check and take on e5
with the
bishop
yeah i guess if bishop f5 through g8
queen yeah it seems like a drawing
by any means you know okay so magnus
tries to spice it
up so but
nice mate after king queen f1 king g4
h5 no
h5 king h5 queen f5 knight g5
g6 and bishop g7
all right actually white is upon down
but it's a drawing
two pawns down what happened two points
down oops
but now it's a bad corner but still
this is a win but he cannot give it up
wow fantastic
you were right the tricks oh
you know what you should draw knight f7
king g8 knight
h6 knight f5 draw look at this
knight f7 jack knight h6 and knight f5
yes bravo it's beautiful
king h8 knight f5 oh
yeah and he didn't find it well with 10
seconds or 20 probably i wouldn't beat
her
in the game
because here no matter how many h pawns
you have
yeah this is why you see i like studies
very much
and then it comes when it i see
something like that
well now it's lost
yeah now it's
all right mr nipponishi
i guess he is lost
he's also lost white is not making too
well today
or at least here
yeah he is completely lost he has no
active ideas well of course he will not
give up
what do you want to see the carlson
technique or the girlfriend technique
well in girlfriend game i think anything
can happen still
here i don't know if uh how much drawing
chances uh vlad has
some he has
but i think they even had a very similar
end game but it was maybe
bishop against bishop carlson had an
also bad bishop but
and but two extra pawns and also he
won't ah but
actually maybe he's gonna save it look
at that he's gonna save it
no oh well now jesus knight
king f7 blunder no not very careful no
this is the only idea what it has but i
think it's a draw after h4
yeah yeah it should be it should be i
will be very surprised if it's not
unbelievable
okay so we have a match
well magnus's face tells it all i think
wow
but okay let's face it it's a fair
result right to make it draw in
in this game yeah from this position
maybe not
was this winning for blackwell sure
right if you're patient
yeah i'm sure i read it in some books
probably it should be no bishop e5 and
then bring the king
or bishop e7 maybe bishop e7
yeah special e7 i was worried the same
nonsense
king h67 k6
knight e4 let's say
maybe the position only wins once the
black bones reaches the fourth rank
maybe not maybe black has to keep his
bishop on the b8 h2 diagonal
that's how he should stop the move
knight g3
maybe that's the secret
so here play some
okay but maybe just play bishop e5 and
uh
okay king g5 ah
okay but it was i thought you had king
sleep
king h4 or maybe bishop f4
king h3 and you just go king f7 king
that'll do it
but nothing is so simple
yeah it looks like ian
yeah it's not so simple yeah
king of eight yarn going for the last
trick g3 yeah
how does black win
well it's not fun to have eight seconds
in such a position
no anything can happen anything can
happen i completely agree queen b8
so if king d5 then rook
d3 king c4
ah okay
so king d5
so he plays it he plays it with seven
seconds left
so he has four extra points
and vladimir made a draw meanwhile so
okay so we can concentrate on this
game so queen g6 or queen g8
in f7 min f7 then
or rook f no i like king d4
like rook h3
oh queen g7
i think once i promote i will win
so jan plays rookie one rook e1
okay king g3 looks nice
wow rook g7
he just wants to promote queen a2 g1
queen d2 king c4 no no king
queen a2 was very strong
so why i know rook g3 and queen c6
so queen v8 i guess g1 now
yeah g1
queen f4 check king
okay but here it's over
i you know i think white had nice chance
to give not queen a7 check because of
course this queen end game is
completely hopeless but to give queen b6
check
and if black doesn't pay attention and
moves his king white takes on
f6 i think it's a great chance
especially online
especially online when you have your
mouse and your king moving right
yeah yeah see alexander you
you played already a lot so you you know
all the practical
chances instincts
it's incredible how resilient chess
players are
getting immediately figuring out all the
opportunities
jan's running out here i'm afraid
yeah this is hard not to win for boris i
think
queen e8 czech and h2
or h2 he went h2 first okay
okay i'm still going
um
maybe it's not so simple with no time
because white king is very nicely
protected from
checks
so boris pins as a b pawn so
to ensure it doesn't match forward
and prepares queen e4 i guess
and if queen g6 he will just march with
his
king to maybe h3
so
boris girlfriend about to equalize this
match against yandeep
machine but i think with half a minute
against computer it will be still very
difficult to win because he will never
blend like losing in
two moves and so you will need to keep
coming up with precise moves
or at least with decent moves so
so now nipponeshi blenders b5 queen a1
check
queen b6 queen d4 queen g1
yeah yes by false
and boris sees it
and place it
is this it
yep
he promised he looks amused okay so some
great excitement
in this round
what's some drama let's have a look at
results
and standings
magnus carlsen he won't be very pleased
with how this game ended
draw us against kramnik one one
then peter swiddler versus anish giri
also won one which means for our
semi-finals
if kramnik wins one of the next two
games doesn't lose one
and geary does the same thing kramnik
can still make the semi-finals
but peter's fiddler remains favorite
ivan chuck anand won one
ding ahead against peter lago one half
half we missed the action there can look
at it no
and girlfriend nepal tight at
one one
actually looking at the final position
there we didn't miss that much action
and
lego ding
yeah also they have nothing at stake
all right then the games will resume in
10 minutes
that gives us a chance to bring in
thank you to ask her about
everything we need to know about the
state of the world
today
yeah and the state of the world is
brilliant just watching this has given
i think all of us so much excitement in
a difficult challenging time and for me
the very very exciting moment of game
of this round two has to be uh i'm just
gonna pull it up it was from vlad's game
against magnus carlsen what an epic save
that was and it was around just give me
a moment
i am just trying to pull it up because
we have to take a look at this
all right so around here
and this moment which judith just found
in seconds i i think this blew my mind
of course
lad was down on the clock had to make a
move fast but he missed this
stunning trick which actually finishes
the finishes the game
instantly uh would have been a draw here
here vlad went knight e6 but instead of
that
found by the strongest female player of
all times
literally in seconds knight f7 check
king has to go to g8 and now knight
eight six check taking advantage of the
fact that the h1 square
and the dark squared bishop are wrong
it's a wrong colored square
if you take on eight six all white has
to do is put the king on h1
and just be around the square and that's
it black cannot win this position
if the only way to continue for black of
course is to go king f8
and after king f8 just knight f5 and
such a pretty tactic because now it hits
the bishop
it hits the pawn on g7 you either take
the pawn on g7 or after g5
again get this ending which is a draw i
think this was absolutely incredible uh
ian and we had
we had social media we had twitter going
crazy about it as well so let's uh
let's pull that up we we heard from
baleed and
uh with judith founding finding this
stunning
tactic waleed said queen is indeed the
strongest chess piece for a reason
the queen here is of course none other
than judith polgar
all right let's move on and
with in that same spirit at that moment
we heard from
agard mehta antonio wrote to us um
antonio himself is a big big legend
a shout out to antonio for all that he
does for the game
judith opie so i learned a lot of you
might be concerned what is opi i
actually learned about it recently
myself so op is
is youtube lingo for overpowered which
means
uh basically awesome and
i think this is time for youtube to go
crazy with the
judith opie so that's what i want to see
on youtube
thank you antonio for writing in
completely agree with that
let's move on
daniel the symbol sounds like great
reason for me to finally join is any
information
daniel thank you so much for writing in
and for considering to go premium it's
just it's a great way to
support all that you see uh the tour
whatever chess 24 is doing for chess
and uh if you're enjoying it definitely
consider it the symbol is one of the
other big reasons
you can if you go premium for two years
or
buy or extend your membership to two
years you guarantee your spot
in the symbol against the world champion
and i have a little bit of info on this
so the first symbol is going to happen
on the 7th of august
you have to to book your spot for the
symbol against magnus carlsen
you have to buy or extend your
membership to a two-year plan
before the 31st of july and the daniel
you were asking me about the time
control i was able to get some info on
that as well
it is it is going to be a 30 minutes
with a 30 second
increment so it's i think that's
that's a very very um it's a very nice
format because you know it's not super
fast play so a lot of you will be
actually able to think
and give the world champion a tough
fight the first symbol is going to
happen again on 7th august and
because we've we've basically been
getting so many entries for this
that uh there's uh there are going to be
multiple symbols uh
depending on the numbers we get that
would be finalized when it happens but
the first one is going to be
on the 7th of august do not forget that
you need to extend your membership
before the 31st of july all right let's
see what else you guys had to say
on twitter we have a world champion who
is superhuman he looks bored when he's
beating his rivals
his parents has before seen this magnus
indeed
um i think undoubtedly we all know the
support
system that magnus's family has been to
magnus carlsen and
i think that's his that's his core
foundation for everything that he's
achieved
in in the chess world his father henrik
carlson you see him everywhere in fact
whenever i played in reykjavik henrik
plays there as well himself now
uh he's been with the world champion his
sisters his mother
definitely i think there's been a huge
role that his family has played
uh he does look a little disheveled when
he comes
on the webcam i have to say it's pretty
different from what we've seen him
in over-the-board chess uh but
it might look like he's just woken up
but the way he plays
it doesn't feel like that at all full
energy full fighting spirit and um
take playing every game till the very
end all right let's move on
so happy to see great judith on the show
such this was again i think
one of the tweets that we received on
that little study like tactic that
judith found
thank you rick for writing in uh before
we move forward with the standings
because i'm being told that the games
are about to start soon
let's um let's take a look at the
current standings
in the event all right so magnus carlsen
is confirmed off the first spot even if
yann nepam yoshi does catch him
uh if magnus loses and yan wins in the
rapid portion
because in their individual encounter
magnus beat yan
he wins on tiebreak uh aneesh
peter it's a very very exciting match
going on in a very important one for
standings because
vlad needs to win his game and if peter
loses to anish in the rapid portion vlad
in fact jumps over and grabs that fourth
spot
also an update for you guys about the
final
four for the very last event of the
magnus carlson chess store which will
take place in august i think it starts
on 9th of august
um but so indeed it does so it's from
august 9 the grand final the grand final
consists of
all the tour all the tournaments in the
tour that have happened the events that
have happened the champion of each of
these events qualifies directly
so magnus carlsen booked his spot by
winning the invitational
daniel dubov booked his spot by winning
the linda asabi
and hikaru nakamura will be the
third finalist in the grand final
uh because if
uh because if because magnus won the
chessable masters
uh which meant that the player with the
maximum number of points throughout the
tour in fact qualifies
for the final hikaru nakamura who
finished who qualified for this he's
been in the semi-finals
and the finals he was so he's got the
maximum number of points throughout the
tour
hikaru nakamura has a confirmed spot
in the final the fourth finalist is
going to be either
the winner of this event but only in the
case if that's
not magnus carlsen if magnus carlsen
wins the whole
legends of chess then ding lyran will be
the fourth finalist there's of course a
lot of math involved i'm not going to
get into that
but basically we've got we've got
magnus hikaru and dubov who are
confirmed finalists
and the fourth spot goes to ding if
magnus wins this event
otherwise whoever wins this event takes
it
in any case that means it's going to be
one heck of a final
all right because we're about to kick
off in like a minute let's quickly get
our next tweet up
and it's
right it's by john and john says
i yan i just wanted to say how much i
enjoy your commentary
because you read the twitch chat really
makes it a lot
more entertaining so thank you thank you
john for writing in to us
and definitely just want to let all of
you know that we
are engaging with you on all platforms
and uh
jan is keeping an eye out on all the
chats whether it's 24 or at twitch so
please keep that coming
and again a reminder that on twitter you
need to use the hashtag
chess legends all right how much time we
got let's take a look at the score
situation before
kickoff of round three in today's
matchups boris kelphin against jan
nevamyashi what a comeback game that
was by boris kelvin he evens the score
and i do see we are joined by jan and
judith
so um yeah and judith your predictions
of how things are going
as well as the next round do you think
seeing the matchups here seeing the way
the games are going
armageddons are we headed towards that
direction
i would say four one ones
will get at least two armageddons
well there is a good chance for that i
think magnus and vladimir will play in
armageddon
wow
magnus has gone 1d4 this time around
does not stick with the italian
and we will wait for
mr komnick to show up
make a move or maybe magnus just want to
see if the board works
put a pawn in the middle there looks
like the other games have not yet
started um
i'm not sure if vichy wants to play
another armageddon he didn't sound very
happy
with the format maybe he will try to
make something happen before that
well does anybody want to play
armageddon
i think magnus he's not happy if he has
to get there because it means it was 2-2
before
but i think he enjoys it nippon is she i
would guess as well i don't know
maybe not he's
so you're you're also not a fan of the
armageddons
i think they're so much fun me well um
i don't know it depends on the situation
and against who i guess
but uh not necessarily have you played a
lot of
online chess do you secretly play do you
have time
no actually i was playing uh quite a bit
when kasparov had his platform back like
15 years ago or something
nearly 20 and
and then i didn't have that experience
that i was
so much into it and after that i was
skipping this opportunity
it's always time to get addicted to
bullet chess
it's not too late yeah i know maybe you
never know
then i have more time just to enjoy the
online chess life
than i might be how are the other games
this is the only one i see moves no if
you scroll up a bit
the other side i'm just an idiot that's
why okay here we are
sorry
what is this
d4 e4 so in
game number one they were discussing
this
yeah it takes changes
d4 e4 and queen a4
trying to stop d5 some funny openings
are
happening but anish
goes d5 cd bishop d7 so what gambit is
this
does it have a name first time i ever
see this
i don't know looks good but probably
white is not going to grab the phone he
is going to play knight c3 or queen b3
i guess
i know do we take
this transposes of course well white can
take the pawn on
here either d5
yeah a lot of tempe is what white is
losing what about taking the
b7 instead of the d5 pawn
bishop c6 queen b you go knight c6 of
course
yes of course jump around
well for a rapid for sure it's a good
interesting choice and probably it's not
too risky either
well so anish probably knows it i don't
think he made this up over the board
and peter looks surprised calculating
can we bail out maybe it's not so easy
even known knight c3 cd queen b3 that
could still be knight c6
looks like peter's surprise was met with
the counter surprise
queen a4 probably he'll think a short
time on that
and how are we going what things are
happening like
nepo's game
still similar to what they were debating
in game one it's the same line let's
bishop g4 bishop d7
embarrass i guess change a bit with rook
fc one
this is the typical same position
is it the same i don't know i can look
it up
yeah he played d5 after bishop e8
the right was this eight here he changed
with rook
fc1 this time around
okay all the same stuff
you can still go bishop d3 so instead of
d5 he went rook fc one right
yeah we start with bishop d bishop d3 he
started with
white can go bishop d3 again
queen b2 is possible
what'd it do on queen b2
so vb2 is possible
but i think bishop these three is also
an
option d5 probably something i wouldn't
go for
yeah e6
but um
i will try queen b2 actually he went
bishop f4 forcing things
yeah it's a typical idea trying to force
the queen here
or here if e5 is maybe bishop g5 or just
bishop g
yeah probably e5 would be too aggressive
bishop g5 and then somehow black's
position is
sometimes there's this move from a bit
oh that's good
but then i think takes and queen f4
would give trouble now fires
we could we could push it
the b7 is not hanging because c takes d4
but maybe bishop d5 maybe bishop d5 can
be unpleasant
yeah but it's kind of
uh interesting they spin i have the
feeling that bishop e5 will be not the
move
or at least let's see what else black
has instead of bishop e5
maybe queen d7
or queen a5 is also possible between
these
queen a5 to have i liked always the
queen on a5
and i played but now i think rook b5
would be unpleasant
so queen c8 we have d5
this is always the critical i think for
uh
for black whether this pawn structure
white can keep
and in the previous game also it was
very
tense for black i think knight e5
obviously
white will be taking i think takes on e5
takes on e5 f4 bishop g7
and again e5 comes
somehow naturally
into our hands and now even f6
is not even possible yet at all i think
bishop on c4 is really powerful
i don't know what e6 d6 bishop c6 let's
say
but it doesn't look good how bad is this
if i insist well d6
queen d5 bishop c6
i don't know queen f7
it looks very
very brave for black doing this i guess
because after look at fake queen e7
no f takes e5 or yeah
yeah always complex
these grunfelds mr grisham is back
zasha which game would you like to see
not just the main ones crown
carlson kramnik and uh
oh he went
knight one to e2
and surprising normally the knight goes
to b3 no after they played this knight
beat knight c1
i don't know i think he just ensured
getting f3 and now
he can get his knight to nice squares
like g3 or
f4 or even i mean maybe he wants already
to play for
like does nothing
i don't know crime late kramnik has some
kind of
you know crutch for those positions with
black
but i don't know i would definitely
prefer white
you're not a fan no
it's a beautiful position for white
isn't it
yeah that's what i think
and b5 okay it's now it's saying that
your leave 4 was so scary that i'm ready
to
completely ruin my position
strategically just
forward i mean i just don't know why
i mean it's just unhealthy position for
black i don't know why
i guess you can play it and then
you it's it's possible to do without
memorizing
uh lines but it comes at a price
you know which i just i mean if you have
to play b5 then your position
i mean it's just it's very hard to
repair it now i mean you need to
i don't know play b4 a5 then exchange
bishops from a6
and then push c5 and then still you are
slightly worse so
so i guess white is going to be playing
knight g3
yeah i guess now anything is possible
then you can even put rook c1
knight can go c3d1 f2 or whatever
it's just i don't know then bishop
goes midnight goes to d3
i don't know magnus should be very happy
with his position
what interesting that magnus is
hesitating he is not fast
playing knight g3 which seems to be the
most logical
or is he just very surprised on
no i mean okay he can now spend some
time decide on the
which setup he wants to get maybe also
he can go
he played knight g3
uh yeah i think it will be a painful
game
i mean the thing is vladimir lost a very
similar game to me
in armageddon in the final of this
charity tournament we had in russia
so also we had this structure and okay i
just
maneuvered my new word and then his
position collapsed
so
we have the first result in ding versus
lako
the players made a draw this is a
well-known theoretical
line so ding probably being up one and a
half half hold draw was good
let's see if liku can come back in the
last game
sasha have you seen this line before
yes yes
in my computer
and peter decided to i guess bailout
with pawn to d6
i think knight cc3 is very good
i mean no no no no no no no i mean in
knight f6 i don't know now there
will be some forcing stuff
i don't know
you know there was some there is some
sort of debate
going on russian internet because
yesterday evgeny barrett
said about anish that he is a pure
tactician has no strategic understanding
and
zero talent naked tactician
and it caused some debate i don't know i
find
such a statement very strange especially
when you are talk i would not say it
about
much weaker player but when you are
talking about
stronger players than you it sounds very
strange
has anish himself involved or he hasn't
he hasn't
i don't think so
i think anish pretends to
having not seen it
now he is busy yeah he is too busy
arguing with
maybe magnus has not seen it yet or he
would have retweeted just to
fuel the flames
of course i strongly disagree anish is a
well-rounded player
great education on the game great
technique great understanding
great openings
yeah i don't know what to say about
their position now
what should like play
completely random
um
yeah it's kind of a lot of tactics here
right
i don't know maybe in some nights if
knight sees
six then we would just take on a photo
yeah
always trying to make this work like 94
94 so then bishop default we should be
before but
yeah but not legal these rules are not
changed yet
yeah bishops can jump
we can show from the
kremlin game no it's a it's one of the
first tricks i learned i've been playing
for this
for years but somewhat never happened
here it's good
all right we should 21 bishop e7
yeah there were simply too many pins and
pawns hanging
so now if dc5 then bc5 and all those
work i mean they work even better but
bishop f2 may be better
yeah sorry
nato one is hard to argue with yeah
so now what will and then bishop g2 is
also not possible because of bishop f2
and knight g4 right
yes and if immediate bishop j to then i
guess black takes on d4 and plays knight
c66
i guess white takes with queen and then
takes only four
and white is should be always knight you
want
i thought we went with me bishop c6 is
not
possible i wanted to play like
queen e4
ah okay and after bishop e7
no i don't know just complete
development somehow
maybe knight f3 or r1
but maybe after knight d5 bishop takes
e7
to exchange the bishops
take stakes knight e4
yeah castle
bishop g2 okay and then bishop c6 maybe
is unpleasant
complications seem to be nice for white
now that happened
maybe he wants uh maybe
yeah but to meet cd with bishop f6 and
94.
exactly and i guess it's
exactly
yeah some strange storage
you know i once played taras in why
kansas against lukewarm
valley and there was this line with this
structure but
with white knight on d5 instead
of a3 yeah but it's not the point
is that okay he played it yeah i played
bishop h3 i won
and after the game he said the worst
thing about it
is that i have a friend who plays
bishop h3 without pawn on hc
so he plays bishop h3 here
and yeah i'm not sure if i explained
this right
so luke played h3 and you took the
opponent no but it was even worse it was
like rookie 8 h3
it was what i didn't lose at temple
moment
okay
so what about taking a look on uh
vladimir's game
all right there is a serious attack
already
yeah knight f4 is a threat
well then at the moment black should go
somewhere king h8 or king fh right
knight f4
oh it looks really bad maybe king h8 was
the only move and rook g8
no but then takes a knight h4 or
something
no it looks really awful
no i don't understand why vladimir
started to play it all the time
he had a very nice opening
but at some point he was doing this now
and he was trying to force the issue
then he lost his game to magnus yeah and
after this he stopped
quit yeah because now i thought this
line was kind of back but
he doesn't feel like doing it
yeah i don't get it
knight h5 plate
well actually probably is the only move
on queen g5
right
but queen g5 is met by f4 but hold on
what
but hold on why not knight h6 first and
then queen h3
ah yes yes question
king f fate only move in h3
no queen g5 knight
yeah looks good game over or something
like that
yeah well i think black's
uh i don't know what he wants but maybe
black has to take on
h6 and queen g5 and then with the phone
down try to
okay
there you have knight g3
well not very good news for black
so is that sure you would recommend
spinning the knight in this situation
this idea of new toys
i've heard no one ever thought of it
before
but i wonder who started to play knight
f3d5963 bishop before because it's
called rock rosin but
i'm not sure he's the one who started it
um because i think also
he was advocating basically playing
those if white let's say now plays e3
or bishop d3 or queen c2 he was playing
knight c6
so he was basically getting this queen
a4 check line
we stamped it down with black
some of you don't get the idea of your
own opening at all maybe your name
shouldn't be on it no
so i just wonder who who started playing
it
i will check sometimes it's called
manhattan no this variation
manufacturing i think is only when it's
uh cd585 bishop g5 that design is 365
and so on
oh maybe
also i'm not sure if manhattan is a
person
probably not
what is this position boris
yep let's count pawns
equal pawns well maybe black is fine
i mean what what danger will black have
on the king's side
knight h e3
whoa what's going on wow c4 nice
nice
what should black do does it become a
race a4 c5
or is there i saw the computer says it's
great for black so maybe there's some
trick
this is interesting
wow what bone structure suddenly
very funny
apparently it's very funny for jan she's
smiling
all the time but he was also smiling a
lot last game when he was a queen down i
can't reach his smiles anymore
yeah he's also of course locked into
second place
maybe it's just a joyful mood
maybe rook f6
we're being informed that manhattan was
a ship
european players traveling on it to a
tournament in the us
in the 30s we're analyzing that
variation okay and i also have an update
so first one to play it with black was
a player named gossip
gossip george george gossip yes
okay then mikhail
then couple games by schlechter uh
three games by marshall two games by
working
two against another
and three more by much and only then
comes
in so sorry get his name on it just
good marketing i don't know i think
no i think we had a book in soviet union
by lipnitsky and uh he was advocating
this setup yeah basically to play knight
c6 no matter what
what he does and maybe in this book he
called it
because i remember it from the childhood
that's interesting good old marshall
also schlester this is much better than
what's called the schlester
no so you should have insisted on this
speaking should be called chinese
slav yeah yeah it's mostly chinese
this is
well we have a draw between evanchuk and
anand
is that correct pretty much played out
hard to continue much from here
okay we missed this one but uh
the boris's game is very interesting and
the
swiddlers also
okay they played this end game well
played game
so now white has the pawn up for the
moment but his king is an f1
and he is in the pin
and sphindler is down in time
yeah and also his position is not very
unviable i would say
well okay he can go queen takes d8 and
rules
c1 right he not he doesn't have
to get worse at all why i will play rkc8
and i will have to do this
and knight f4 knight c5
yeah knight c5 rook c5 my back rank is
is sensitive there
c6 plate by
peter benjaminovich swiddler
okay this seems to be a good move so
is he planning to meet bc sixth with
just
with what with queen a4 or what what's
his
but it's very strange being a
photographer between a5 or pc
okay can we survive
something like this
this probably not not this one
looks bad no rook c1
doesn't look good though i don't know
peter
always gets such positions in english
against marinus he had
you know that's a very similar one
he cannot compete complete his
development
c4 does not contribute to castling
so we have on the board rook c1
uh what is white next move like
something like queens
knight f4 maybe queen c4
knight f4 runs into bishop d2 bishop d2
right i don't know so it's i'm not sure
so maybe queens oh even that is not the
end of the world rook c4
yes but black will have one some move
played by
bishop f5 so what is this
ah maybe
maybe he was afraid of taking only four
and f3
he wants it well he just doesn't want to
allow right to get
out so easily with his king from f1 i
guess
so knight f4 i guess bishop g2 yes
he plays it then e1 takes on f4 rook d8
and somehow black is very fast
yeah white will need
sort of a miracle to escape
probably rookie one or something oops
rook c6 was taken
wow supposed strategy
brave choice
yeah but it's great v8 yeah
well i think his braveness out of
desperation
rook b8 yeah i don't see a difference e4
well what is it seems like pretty much
of desperation for white
or e3 maybe
b
so if peter is going down he's gonna
need some help
from magnus looks like it's incoming
though if
magnus wins this game then peter makes
the semi-finals
well it seems so madness is going to
crush a lot here e4
very shortly coming or even f4 f5
so e3 is on the board at svidler's game
there are some good tactics will happen
i think
bishop takes e3 happened
also after fe3 there was a rugby
and now also so what will happen here
something very fishy would be too
the wraith was right here just tactics
what what other tactics group d2
rook d2 k1
maybe just d5 no
so how to win by force
no but maybe simply queen d7
also rook g8 looks nice just to bring
the left that's yeah i need to play
queen e5
also decent quite promising
swiddler resigns this is
checkmate
yeah rough game was a good move
more to argue yeah
if he does rook g2 or is there a mate
with checks i think so
everything is hanging and collapsing for
white
so let's see how
magnus is doing
e4 c3
and magnus is smiling
he looks extremely happy
but he said in some interview yeah that
beating kramnik is the best feeling
he's too happy to just yes it's
disgusting to watch i mean
when someone is so happy
but okay he has to find a win
which probably there is not only one
so let's say eg5 queen d5
if rook is six queen in six rookie one
there is bishop
too so that's actually maybe a way to
spoil it
even this must win maybe after
d5 at the end
23 queen f2
yeah even even the blender means for
white i guess
uh
yeah actually maybe this this would be
the computer's choice
rook f2 king f7 on the board
yeah this is the human choice
no more smiling though
almost almost i think he's containing
himself
yeah queen queen h3 seems not bad
wow event takes f4 looks good to
four what is this f4 d takes e4
i guess f5 f5 and h4 on knight g5 right
well the problem for vladimir it's just
too winning it's just completely winning
so white can do what he please
oh okay i found maybe some way to
blender with right so it's knight take
d4
and let's say you might place queen
takes c3
d4 rookie 4 and now rook c8
okay
that's slightly cooperative right
but yeah well after rook city it's still
queen e3 or queen e1
right some
knight f8 only move
maybe rookie 4 is decent as well no
it looks great yeah
okay at least black keeps one of those
pawns so if
if queen takes c3 then he has bishop
no i think after looking for he will go
to c8 actually
yeah and if rookie 4 looks it so at
least i mean
as long as one of those pawns is alive
there is some
little yeah there is some hope
though f6 and rookie 7
no or rookie 7 is not good enough after
knight g6
takes queen g i know f e f e seven
yes mini five will grab seven queen c
five mate
rule okay what to do
turns out there's not that many
defenders around the king
maybe rook b8 is a kind of still
fighting
well h4 he plays it
so at least he creates a thread
and now even queens takes c3 i guess
it's possible
b1 rookie one and if queen take g4
there is queen c7
but okay magnus played h3
not h4 not queen c3 h3
k2 in his
famous games
although if it's in reaction to a check
it's less impressive no like
yeah okay
so queen b8 i think some rookie 5 now
will be played
magnus is completely bored
but he would like it to be written
already the point for
him and there's all the sunlight in his
face
yeah it's a sunny day
i guess he's back in norway no he said
he was off the boat
yeah now it reminds me um
okay one my friend he had a game uh
in a symmetrical g3 greenfield
he made you know sacrifice he played at
some point e4
black played d4 he played d5
and black played e six take d5 and then
he
made some quiet move so i guess
maybe he landed something and then he
fought fought for
a long time but finally lost and then
his friend
said to him no you were playing so good
so good but the problem is that you
ran out of poems
and it's the problem with vladimir's
position so what's the balance
if you have like a knight and a bishop
as a rook
how many pawns does white need here five
is probably better for
the side with the rook no i think let's
say if we exchange the rooks
and we remove a2 g4 and h3 pawns it's
still
winning two pawns are still winning
normally right
yeah i think so yeah yeah at least even
h3 and g4 is very difficult to defend
and but
fng is definitely
so yeah there is not much chance that
vladimir can squeeze out of this
position
and this would be with all joking aside
if cramming loses this game he's out of
the tournament so it's understandable
he fights till the very bitter end
literary will be
magnus seems very conscious not to allow
any chances
maybe after that last game it's extra
focused
what do you do rookie two no
well i guess anything right yeah but
rookie two
looked the best
these guys keep debating queen and games
this one will not end well for
boris what is this famous position
that's a little different no like
like this but it's unlikely good self
mate
yeah it's almost like this just
one square for if black
queen moves one square we have it
such a subtle game chess one square
can make all the difference
okay this is hopelessly
oh king one here we are
oops another chance
three times no computer bar went up so
it's probably a mistake
not sure why is it
three times why didn't he take on g5
no it doesn't look like our they are
still having this position
draw maybe two and you're right
wow so let's try to count one
and jan is smiling again
he's very pleased with the amusement
provided by this match
magnus making progress
all other games are over so gail found
the bombing sheet drawn
like ding there was a very quick draw
evan shook anand pretty faster as well
and svidler lost with white to giri good
news for him is magnus castle is
completely winning
and if magnus wins then swiddler makes
the semi-finals
however probably he would have to face
magnus if he loses the match
to anish i'm not sure what happens if he
wins in armageddon
then there are titan points
you know when i see those uh
smiles which have no apparent reason i
always remember
a russian joke like when kids go to some
you know construction
work you know with their
school mates yeah with their classmates
and the teacher said to them that you
have to
wear cask you know protect
you because we had one
case that a couple kids went there
so a girl was wearing a
the boy was not and something followed
them
boy died and the girl just loved
smiled and walked away and one of the
kids said
yeah i know that girl she's still
wearing a cask and
he's smiling
it's very dark yeah
magnus vladimir playing not wearing any
helmets
um yeah and kramnik has seen enough
he resigned okay this was not a good
opening for vladimir
actually it was not he couldn't have a
great fight
in there that means that
we know our semi-finalists
kramnik is out he put up a great fight
but that
that loss to swiddler cost him in the
end because now
the only question that remains is who
will finish third
our semi-finalists are magnus carlsen
yeah that's number one and number two
and then if peter swindler wins his
match against anish kiri
even in armageddon have been informed
he's third well if he loses
which currently has to be a favorite
then anish is third
and swiddler is fourth
so peter swiddler needs
a comeback victory with the black pieces
not gonna be easy but might as well try
that means that peter is
the only legend to make it to the
semi-finals
which probably will be consolation that
going into this tournament he was the
only legend i believe
who was not involved in a world
championship match if we can't
bona marijuana but
i believe this has to outweigh all the
other legends successes
and we will bring in tanya
to celebrate
the semi-finalists and the game of chess
hashtag grow the game
yeah no celebration of chess is complete
unless we talk
about one of the biggest legends in the
history of chess
bobby fisher and i i think judith is
going to stay with us for a little bit
to that a lot of people in chat were
talking about this and i think for those
who who might not be aware uh
bobby fischer after his 91 match
against the boris paskey i think it was
in 91 or 92 that he could not return to
the us
and in fact was in hungary and stayed in
the polga household for
uh for a summer i think it was and uh
judith this is something we all want to
hear about the
experience what it was like to spend
that time with a legend like bobby and
the impact it had on you
yes after his sweater sweaty stefan
match in 92 i think
against baskey he was still staying in
in that area and in the end of the year
i think or beginning
yeah end of that year later we visited
him where he was staying with
my parents and sophia susan was not
there because she was doing something
else
and somehow he was an interesting person
it was of course we were shocked that we
are meeting uh
legend as bobby we didn't even think
about it
that that it will be possible ever and
then my father was telling him how great
hungary is we have great things
great food great thermal bus and anyway
the city is beautiful
and then he was kind of bored alone
there and he couldn't go back to the
states probably he didn't want to either
but then shortly afterwards he moved to
hungary and then he was staying in one
of the most
known hotels at the gallart i think but
then
he moved to some private place
private apartments staying and hiding in
hungary because he never liked it when
people recognized him or
went to him he he was a very interesting
personality but
it was also
i got mixed feelings about it later on
when he was coming over
on daily basis as of course he
he shared his views about chess but
mainly about his phonetic beliefs that
the prearranged games
and he wanted very much that the
fischer random chess will replace
regular chess because theory is killing
the game
and uh but he was always very joyful
very happy and smiley he was like
childish pretty much but it was it was a
huge contrast because he was a
huge guy with a huge size of food
like i don't know he was like 48 or
something i don't know really big
feet he had appetite he loved hungarian
food
he was famous that whenever he visited
to
restaurants he was eating very much so
people
remember that and and also some of his
friends
friends were coming over to hungary
visiting like eugene torre was here once
and of course paul banco was already
staying in hungary visiting him
and later on i think he got friends with
laco
and some other people and i think he had
a great time here in hungary because he
loved the thermal bus he was very
fanatic about that
and and then later on in the summer of
93
he also came to our summer house
and he had his bodyguard with him all
the time
as he was quite a much
freaking out if anybody was close to him
apart from the people who he didn't know
and so it was a very interesting
experience and
exceptional but sometimes i think okay
what would have happened if i never met
him
probably i would have a different
opinion or feeling about bobby but
i don't regret it of course that i met
him because
it's a memorable experience even though
maybe not necessarily
everything was positive
very uh fascinating dude you say that
you had
mixed feelings about it and uh i'm
is that coming from just his the fact
that he was such a genius and you know
you
you admire him over the board but
because his extreme beliefs
sometimes uh it made it hard
for you to agree with them was it the
off board
off the chessboard part part of it that
made it a little difficult
or have these mixed feelings first of
all it was it was a pity that he never
wanted to
really play chess real chess he was
always talking about the pre-range games
of the
long decades before played the games
world championship matches between
kasparov and karpov
the big old candidates tournaments
all those stories which he started out
saying already back then he was keep
still saying and repeating and
so i've been much more happy to discuss
the
actual situation to play chess with him
which we did with the fischer random
chess we played the doubles but even
that he was he was not some
thing that he wanted to do too often so
he was more
engaged and with the topics he was
obsessed about
and so this is this is the thing which i
would have preferred to talk more about
the real chess stuff
it to me it sounds i can just imagine
this uh really young judith just all she
wants to do is play chess with a former
world champion and
with a great like uh fisher but all
that he's doing is uh uh talking about
stories and his beliefs and i can
imagine you just
waiting for that moment when you can
have that game against him
what in your opinion judith if do you
do you think if that match in um in 75
between
uh bobby and between bobby fisher and
karpov had actually happened
i mean it doesn't really matter anymore
because it
what do you think would have been the uh
the result
i don't know because it's
it's very difficult to say but i know
that once when i was talking about this
match with karpov as he was also
visiting
to us uh some period of time i was
training with karpov and
sometimes we discuss this and i had the
feeling that
anatoly said something like that that
at the time bobby was better than him so
then at that point i think it would have
been very close
and possibly karpov would not have
become world champion right there
but of course we'll never know this
yeah it's just uh it's just conjecture i
think that's one of the world
championship matches that
did not happen and uh the entire world
missed out on what the
legacy of that match could have been i
think it was
it was cass pro as well who later said
either kochna or casper
um correct me if anybody in chat knows
uh
who this was that said that probably in
the 75 match
fisher would have won but carpo would
have been able to qualify for the next
world championship
and then carpo would have won so of
course all of this is conjecture because
bobby never played after the 72 world
championship match uh
uh defending to defend his title
judith we also had a question from one
of our from our viewer let's get that
up on the screen and
it's interesting because i think it's
such a different era talking about bobby
and talking about
the legends of chess as it's happening
right now in front of our screens
looks like two different worlds and
ganal has a question
for that saying which was better the
chess world before
or after computers and you did you
mentioned that this is something that
even uh
fisher spoke to you about that how
theory
which of course the chess engines had a
lot to do with is
is really killing the beauty of chess i
know it's hard to compare different
times because
chess has evolved so much the
characteristics are different
but what in your view was uh the golden
period for chess
before computers or after
actually i'm a person who don't like to
to go back in time so much and
and say that that was better or not i
like to be living in the actual time and
looking
ahead of the future but of course the
game of chess was very different
i remember when i started out playing
chess
absolutely we were having the chessboard
front of us
even if we had trainings of having blind
games
but everything was paper based
everything was
uh was what you learned the you
memorized
your intuition uh you were secretly
keeping your notes and having your
novelties maybe for for weeks months or
even
years which is quite difficult nowadays
with the
with the computers and engines and i
remember i had this strong struggle
uh starting using the engines in the
early 20s in the early 2000s
year 2000 and so on um
the sport is just a different game i
think we need completely different
skills
to be successful and and i think in
some ways this is the the difference
between the new generation and the
the old one that in chess understanding
the older generation
is in some ways much better but the
newer generation
they can ex somehow they can use
all the different possibilities which
exist
out there right now and they are using
it in
a very flexible way like in long many
years ago when i was playing chess
and many other players you can you could
afford having one or two openings
with black let's say maybe but nowadays
obviously you have to have many
different
openings you have to be very flexible on
that you have to be picking up different
openings
ideas and be ready to play few hours
after you looked at it because in a week
later
time is going to be not actual no
no no use of it anymore so
but back to the question that which
period of time was
better when i was playing it of course
creativity was very
actively part of the game of home
preparation and also at the board
but now psychology also was very
different
then and now i believe
i think every period of time has its uh
charm and
and the the top players has to
understand what it takes to be on the
top level
at the time when they are they are there
and
of course there were a lot of people who
had extremely fantastic preparation for
example
and that meant a lot and uh
um so i i it's very difficult for me to
say of course one of the most special
area of chess era was when
kasparov karpov was playing head to head
i mean that was something very special i
think for
quite a few years they were the top two
being very much ahead of the others
so it it seemed like it's they will be
there for endless time
but then some people were coming and
challenging them yeah fair enough it is
very difficult to compare and like you
said that
every every period had its own uh
had its own charm and beauty in the game
and i think a very important point
judith that you made was that
for the top players to be able to stay
at the top
it's extremely important to keep
adapting yourself and evolving yourself
to the changing nature of the game
and this has been a constant topic of
discussion in the legends of chess which
is the longevity of a career there have
been many great players in the past who
have not because they've not been able
to move on and get into the computer era
of chess
have dropped out but a lot of players
and especially the legends that we see
in this tournament
are the ones who've kept their place at
the very elite because they've actually
found this change that has come about in
our game
the different trends that have come over
time something that's given them
motivation to keep working on it
and they have evolved and adapted
accordingly and we also
we also had a really nice tweet from a
friend of yours judith
it's by juga in fact i saw her new song
called
immortal game recently we all saw that
on the broadcast as well
and you feature in that song you're in
that video and i know that uh both of
you
are uh are friends uh and juga says that
i'm working on a new chess song about
top 10 chess
blunders for uh any ins any suggestions
for your favorite blunders to be
immortalized uh do this at the top of
your head if there was one blunder that
comes to your mind
which one would it be my own blonders
it could be your own or something that
you have seen but just
like the first blunder that comes to
your mind with this
um unfortunately they're
quite a collection i think out there uh
but i remember when vlad was blundering
against the computer
uh fisher bishop h2 in the match but
there are there are many others it's uh
i think uh
you have to make a great search on that
generally speaking i think um
i don't know which was my blunder the
biggest to be honest
i think it's great that you can't
remember yeah yeah i have a good
selective memory it works because also i
feel that blunders are something
that you don't really learn anything
from you know you can you only get
better at chess
and the amount of blunders you make uh
gets reduced
so it's just best to block the blunders
out that you make but i agree with you i
think that
uh spassky fisher game in a drawn
end game where fisher went bishop h2 and
lost that game is definitely i think
a blunder juga that you need to use uh
for your next one
uh judith the games are going to begin
soon so if you want to get a cup of
coffee or a drink i am you go even
though it's very hard for me to do that
but i must
so please feel free to um to join us in
a bit
until then let's update our audience uh
to the current score situation going
into the final round of the game
of the match so we've got an even score
between boris and jan and i have to say
that that's quite impressive
a very in-shape quick playing gyan is
not finding it very easy against the
oldest of the legends
boris gelfin tingler and peter lecko
ding taking the lead on that
vaseline took vishwanathan on and
another legendary clash
is even going into iran for peter switla
up against
aneesh giri anish has taken a lead in
that
peter needs to win on demand to make
that
um to make that into the armageddon
magnus carlsen
also won the game which means that
vladimir kramnik
must win the next game to take it to
armageddon but this
means that our semi-finalists the four
semi-finalists are
already confirmed the reason for that is
that vladimir kramnik
needed to beat magnus carlsen in the
rapid portion
to have a shot at qualifying but now
that the best case scenario is that the
game goes into an armageddon
let's bring up the current standing one
more time
and take a look at the semi-finalists
and congratulate them
magnus carlson nakamyashi aneesh kiri
peter swiddler are going to be
continuing the event
these are the four semi-finalists and
the big question now remains is between
the game of anish and peter
if peter is able to win on demand the
next game
and then win uh in the armageddon peter
gets
moves on to 16 points while anish stays
at 15
and that would mean that magnus plays a
niche and yan plays peter in the semis
so still a lot to fight for for the
players here
and we've got yan uh in with us he's
joined us
so i'm gonna throw a question to him
yeah what's your prediction do you
do you think who's gonna play magnus
carlson in the semis
i will make the bold and risky
prediction
that peter swiddler will not win on
demand
with the black pieces and then win the
armageddon
so he will play magnus in the semis
and svidler sometimes he sounds a little
over
optimistic about his chances and i think
some humility
would do him well like sometimes
understanding
he's not perfect and that things have
gone his way in some of these games
so i hope he will take this challenge
seriously
to face magnus three days in a row and
not just think
it's a walk in the park and i will just
crush that kid but i'll talk to him and
make sure
that you know he understands things
could go wrong
peter uh jan with your predictions you
really do live life on the edge i must
say that uh it's always
always pushing the envelope
indeed and um let's get the pairings up
and should we do a quick
yay and nay for armageddon now that
we're into the final game all right
boris versus yan
um let me check this score who's white
yan is white
sorry i'm not very fast nay nay young's
gonna win
i say nay as well we're on the same team
on this one ding versus peter
all right peter versus anish nay
you said that already your hot take on
that match and what about
magnus vs vladimir nay
i i don't know if you have enough time
to bring up that tweet by leon oh we do
have kickoff so i'm going to have to
leave you here yan
no worries by the way we should mention
that nippon
she has improved on his play in game
number two where he played a3
and this time he went knight a3
it's good he's taking this seriously at
least he's developing his pieces this
time
yeah yeah all right over to you guys
thanks tanya this is i think swaginsev
was experimenting
with this move two knight to a3
and they promised oh my is improving on
2a3 unit what do you think
i see nepo has a special relationship
with the a3 square now
yeah today and
fortunately if this goes to armageddon
there are no more pieces he could try to
put on a3
maybe he'll be already move on his
position is not so bad knight a3 is not
such a bad move because it covers this
bishop on b5 potentially after some
knight d4s
well eventually he plays c3 knight c4
knight c2 wherever and
things will be in order no it's very
playable or even takes on c6 and knight
comes to c4
it's yeah it's not the end of the world
we'll see what happens
it just looked very strange moved to
knight a3
it's kind of we have to admit that it's
this is exactly what what we say to
people right who starts learning
chess never go to the side with their
knight
bring the knights to the center castle
yeah but maybe this is also changing i
don't know
did you ever have a training session
with the late mark veretzky you must
have had no huh
actually i didn't my sister had sofia
he had one session of two weeks or
something like that
but i know his books and of course i was
analyzing that because with varetsky
this guy's fiancee was his
favorite student so for me we had like
two sessions with the
german federation was very frustrating
he would give you some incredibly tough
puzzle and then he would tell you
swearing seth sold this
in one minute and you would sit there
for half an hour don't understand
anything
this position is fair and safe seems to
have solved as well
zasha did you did you hear the same yeah
yeah i hear you
what do you want to say yes uh
explaining to me that the point
of knight a3 is that black is
in kind of swank in this position
but white is also because
knight f3 blocks f pawn
which is relevant for you know for some
let's say in some rosso limos uh you
really
maybe sometimes want your knight to be
away from f3 yeah even sometimes white
plays h3 knight h2 then f4 and like this
yeah
yeah yeah yeah
so and let's so knight f3 blocks the f2
pawn
c3 allows knight f6
so yeah and then f4 allows g5
and so on so that was the point of
knight
so black isn't super fun a6 how bad can
it be
a6 i don't know now maybe c3 is a very
decent move
maybe we don't know let's have a look
around
swiddler in a must win
must avoid did no region
it's going for the pierce
anishie's lost some games in these lines
in the
past he usually got good positions but i
think
against nippon she lost one in vike
maybe
yeah and he lost a decisive game against
chunk
strong as well
but now anish is leading to one exactly
so that's why peter goes for it yeah
my co-host wants to say hi
big chess expert
my own computer well i'm curious how
swiddler wants to mess up the position
but of course it's a must-win situation
and so he has to do something
to try out something right
and what about the other games
can we see maybe magnus's game because
it looks
very tactical sharp sicilian
and
also it seems like the players
are possibly getting tired
yeah g5 h5 is there
so so i guess castle is met by
b4 now yeah and
why it cannot even play knight g5
because of knight take this reject and
there will be
right no i don't know then it's unclear
but of course knight b3 is the simplest
then take
yes so so that email goes g6
uh instead of castilia
yeah so let's see
oh he went for g6 already
yes
i've never seen the magnus playing
something like this with black
no it's uh somehow
i remember i was playing tons of blitz
games with my sisters when i was a child
these kind of positions the sicilian
different side castling
so will magnus play h6 or something or
b4
i think i don't even know maybe
also bishop f6 is an option
bishop f6 is also a typical
characteristic move of this kind of
position
i think after g6 bishop f6
is always at least the move to consider
but now maybe knight d5 sometimes it's
possible
or is it too early
i don't know
okay gary's game
e5 gear is straight forward i guess he
wants to go e6
after text x knight g4
and i think the important point is that
if before then after ef6 this is
frequency series
c6 is hanging
you mean after f takes e5 knight g5
no no no no i mean after e5 because
a typical reaction to e5 is b4
yeah but
okay takes on f6 bc3 queen c3
bishop f6 queen c6 spawn up
yeah and actually black maybe has some
little compensation like he has nice
structure but
i mean it's not what you
would like well it's not what he was
aiming for i think
yeah so after e5 uh peter is thinking
how to try to move not g4 he played
immediately
that's kind of logical
so after e5 he went knight g4
so now he takes d6 is an option
he takes back no maybe bishop g5
i think white has an extremely safe
position
yeah and black cannot move away he's
king king queen to a5 because it's queen
e2
so actually it's very safe for white
yeah and sometimes black plays e6 in
such positions but
not in this one yeah but anyway you go
bishop g5 i think
yeah yeah yeah exaggerating right knight
can go to e4
c5 no of course of course but sometimes
it's an
idea in this modern position
he takes d6 e takes d6 is on the board
and yeah bishop g5 somehow is inviting
and magnus meanwhile played your move h6
and yeah because h6 is not funny when
white is
playing it right yeah but now queen g2
is an option
and then bishop f6 i guess and maybe
take h6
but there uh maybe already knight b3
bishop c3 or even f
oh dimmer goes knight d5
wow well it was kind of
expected that something firework will be
happening but i don't see how fast he
can do that takes
bishop d5 queen c7
and now white has to be extremely fast
if g takes f7
will black play rook f7 or king goes out
and magnus played queen e8
instead
so
okay i don't see a way to really
continue an attack
but let's see
what did i miss some kindergarten here
as well
kramnik gave up a piece
yeah he definitely wants to win but
maybe he gives up too much too early
and peter has his king on f8
well he's desperate he didn't want to
exchange queens
but it's it's not very nice
bishop f4 knight b6
okay then at least there is some
yeah he brings his knight to d5 he
develops his bishop
sometimes g5 i wonder what
would happen if white played
94 instead of a castle
good move knight b6
ah so you just go you're
yes that was exactly my idea okay so
knight b6 and then later i go h6
oh yeah maybe okay so they now yeah
so knight e4 queen e4 d5
it's still playable but of course it's
uh to play for a win with black it's
it's not so obvious
yeah this looks like an uphill struggle
for peter
no maybe g5 now g5 g4
yeah g5 backs to be played and to ask
ah no but then bishop d2
and if g4
i guess okay let's say 91 yeah
how is it d5 bishop b4 king g8 bishop d3
bishop
d4
c3 and f3 right
or just knight c2 well i go back bishop
g7
knight c2
no this is not what anybody wants to
play with black
no
okay so of course the opening didn't
work out for
peter
looks like he will have
three days or maybe two days against
magnus
and first they have a res day right
tomorrow's a free day everyone can catch
their breath
and then it continues with the
semi-finals where the players play
not one match like here but it's this
best of three format so you need two
points
to move on therefore it's minimum two
days of these matches
maximum three
grams sacrificing some more pieces
okay so let's see what he has in mind
gh
somehow i have the feeling that he does
it really doesn't have enough here
i mean bishop i don't know
yeah it's hard to believe
i mean white hasn't even castled yet
too much pieces are off the board
for white
that is there to block the g5
yeah so last game he ran out of ponds
now he's running out of pieces
always problems with that not nice not
nice to have this situation
no there is
no he seems like
the problem so what's going on in the
other games
swiddler is uh okay let's go for evancho
let's do a quick round yeah actually
evan shook
very serious games they're debating this
theoretical line
for quite some games as mentioned i
don't like
this knight b7 and eventually also
switched to this line which is more
solid
here i'm sure there are many
podkin files on the subtleties of bishop
d2
91 or queen e2 first but
it looks quite quite balanced i guess
they're both okay with repeating moves
here maybe
lekko
and he he has a good position
yeah at least an interesting one
at first it looks nice for white but
maybe for second
thought maybe it's not but maybe he can
play queen d3
and f5 efc
and then to take on b7 and
then g6 queen h7 and queen g6
checkmate
so you take with the knight i guess yeah
i take or maybe i take on c5 if you take
with this knight i will take on c5
just to avoid maybe because maybe when i
take b7 you will play
c4
oh yeah there okay and this one is
definitely better
i mean the only thing black has is the
f4 square
yeah okay maybe even gc
but this must be better
i don't know
well maybe queen d3 g6
yes but queen this eg sees then it's
another story
then okay then it's
windy to king g7
h4
queen d3 g6 on the board
but his girlfriend
needs to win to force i know it's one
have one enough
so whoever wins wins the match
i guess black's fine
well black seems okay
black seems more than okay
somehow even against knight a3 boris got
his usual structure from this bishop b5
e69
although they have repeated the moves
once
what plague knight e6 in order to go d5
but the thing is this is already
something they had i think it was bishop
on h6 and black played knight f4 and
white played bishop g5
oh yeah i know it was slightly different
thing around okay
and draw a grit here as well two draws
yeah so they go on for the armageddon
is smiling again can't get enough of the
action today
and anandivanchuk as well i'm reading
that ivan shook his black in the
armageddon it will start
in nine minutes that means vishyana with
the white pieces
five minutes versus four fish needs to
win
at least he has a head start on the
clock
sliddler queens are off
still hard to win
what is
well it's the rookie one is also very
tempting but bishop f5 can be also very
tempting
is it on the board no a5
a5 so what happened on knight
c4 ah he just wants to take in rook a4
maybe
but then at the end d7
bishop g3 f5 ah and the f5 then you take
on b4 and b7
tactics
no you can go b c 3 b c and f 5.
yeah but then
well it's hard to imagine that uh gary
would be blundering something
magnus carson in the meantime has won
his match
and all his matches in this tournament
are
defeating well done kramnik
went for it he ran out of pieces
no actually kramnik ran out of energy of
or ideas after game two it seems
yeah but also i mean the opening choice
in
game three is i will repeat yeah
yeah he already after the opening he had
a very difficult position
also you know magnus is not a type of
opponent you
avoid theory and get just
worse position out of something
also magnus enjoys his cause but
structures i know from my own experience
all right that means the question that's
remaining
is will peters fiddler force an
armageddon
if not he's facing carlson and
yanni pomneshi will face anishgiri
also always some tension i think in the
last last of these tournaments they play
in the semi-finals anuj one
the publisher has looked much better in
this one so far seems like he's been
improving throughout this tournament
so another interesting battle forward
we have two armageddons in the making
will be
anand eventually first and then the
eponymous elven
predictions who's going to win vishy
or evanchuk my prediction is
okay then i take vichy and boris
just for you the time i'm with krishuk
on that one
i'm also going in you also chucky and
nepo yeah sasha
okay
peter played this bc this is what we had
on the board right
rook b1 atlantic
f6 f4
uh rook c4 you have android 6 or cap7
anish said no messing around let's
exchange this
okay he doesn't want to have
even a thought about an armageddon
yeah he is he's played very cynically
and we are being joined by
the world champion who's won his final
match
magnus how's it going
so good how was your match
now it seems that in the last few
matches
to use a football analogy i'm
getting like levandovsky level chances
but i'm
converting them at a firmino level
and for those who don't watch football
that's pretty bad
um but
at least um the
last two games were sort of okay but he
he is playing
it's kind of suicidal in both of both
of those games so i didn't really have
to do all that much
alexander was very critical of his play
in the opening in game three did you
feel you were you were much better there
out of the opening already what's the
structure
yeah i felt like um he
was a bit too compliant so i got very
decent play
um i mean b5 is a typical idea
but i in general it seems better when
there are dark squared bishops on the
board than
than without because that now
i mean all of these ideas with going b4
and then c5 they don't seem very
attractive like it's always always going
to be words
and then i guess um when he actually
went for c5
in the game it doesn't doesn't work
technically
um yeah when he has to go c4 immediately
like if he moves the king
e4 is just crushing so no no no no
i mean after c4 the after
let's say king h8 i just take on c5 if
he does that immediately
um uh and i mean in the game
i probably missed a million wins earlier
but
um it was never really in doubt
we saw you had a very big smile on your
face somewhere around here after e4 was
that
joy about your position or other factors
as well
no i probably thought of something funny
but i cannot
i cannot like offhand tell you what that
was but the position was pretty good
then game number four were there any
crucial moments well he did just didn't
work
yeah uh i think knight d5 doesn't work
at all
but i mean i have no clue about these
positions
um in general but
i i mean like my take would be that
either
in this position in general either white
is winning or black is winning
there is just no
there's just nowhere in between because
the all the long-term factors
except perhaps skin safety all the
positional factors are so much in favor
of like the
white really needs to to mate quickly
but i have i have no clue
i think it's winning for black winning
for white or red
no i don't think draw i think draw is
very unlikely
no actually the engine thinks it's zero
zero zero after queen d2
and then sacrifice on h6
okay yeah
i don't know whatever it could be
and we asked you about the game two
where you played knight c6 what you had
in mind were you
thinking already that you're winning on
the spot
or uh
wherever in in game two i think
after knight c6 no you mean game one
was it game one
yeah the italian
oh okay got it
here yeah no i mean i
i thought for too long basically like
obviously like the hand wants to go
knight f5
and you feel like that's uh
that's resignation but i sort of
i i suddenly got this idea that to go
knight c6 and take on a5
and uh i had this
nice little trick with uh queen c7
uh with uh if he goes rook d8
after knight a5
uh that that was sort of the point that
i wanted to go knight b7 the knight a5
to
the c6 but actually even this doesn't
work as a queen 88 and then
and then rook g8 so yeah
i guess the moral of the story is don't
try this at home
uh just go
just go knight f5 and win the game
without calculating a single variation
would be would be a
joint
yeah because it was a really a clear
huge advantage what you did in the last
10 moves in this game
previously to this oh yeah i mean
i would be very surprised if white is
just not
it is i don't think like it's even a
question of winning i think it's just
dead last for black for probably
well we're evading the vicion and
armageddon
starting here we are magnus you want to
stick around
no not really i i mean this this game
has
very little effect
more than i don't know
or flagging right is that the right term
that is the term okay thank you
enjoy your rest day and we'll see you
the day after tomorrow
congrats thanks both armageddon started
at the same time it looks like
we're not even staggering now vishy
anand versus vasil ivanchuk and
yami pomneshi against boris girlfriend
so again by cd plays some rare line
um
yeah and there is a funny pawn structure
here
yeah but white has an easy play yeah
i mean by silly
like something more
you know more demanding from the
opponent
here it's
you can play natural almost
he's been very fast so far i guess now
he will take and play c5 yeah
h5 go for it yeah okay yeah but it's not
a checkmate yeah and they have it
and they play this is the position we
have
okay yes cd4 cd4 i guess some bishop
this
i don't know what no i'm not sure maybe
bishop d7 bishop c6
yes
if i can go maybe d5 and king f1
king of well 95 if you play screen f5
okay okay i guess
king of one now
maybe d2 but it doesn't look
but still what else when you do is the
background
oh queen d2 he went
bad provisions
okay king e3
still not over
ah d2 was a very nice move here
this king sort of substitutes
a pawn and now in white pawn chain
bishop c6 bishop d5 i guess
rook d6
it's on the board bishop f6
yeah now everyone will double and black
will play king
of eight i guess and then how to make
progress with white this will be the
biggest i think he will push g pawn okay
so he plays rook c1
maybe we'll just get a good
old-fashioned clock banging session
bishop e4 that's the plan
yeah she's
okay still some play
yeah i wouldn't be happy
is there anything if it takes on e4 fe4
bishop e5
f takes e5 root d7 and i just go king e7
next
oh i don't know but it's so dangerous
one and e5
yeah d1 and g5 then king can come to g5
i don't know so then
something else happened he went
so actually and fun has is winning so
at the moment it looks like judith will
2-0
okay so how is this
well i don't think there is much chance
for chucky
there takes he's also behind on the
clock
f4
king d3 vicious doesn't even want to put
his pawns on dark squares locate to h2
rk6 is awesome
well this is gonna win i think how is
the girlfriend's game going clock is
also fine so let's switch to napoli
girlfriend
where
clock could still very much become a
factor
yeah but now bishop b5
knight b4 yeah
and a7 knight can be in trouble
king comes king goes
and still king e3 only move knight c2
knight a3
king c3 king b4
uh i think girlfriend could play knight
c4
check now okay now it's
not so clear yeah yes but for him draw
is enough too
yes but that's why you should change one
pair of nights
what a nice setup four nights there
knight d4 e6
get from playing at a very decent pace
but
and now knight three g4 yes this was
nice
knight c6 well played it's very good
nice technique king c4
playing incredibly well well if you play
with boris you don't mess around in
end games
knight d4 ah also good
offering some move repetitions
ah just this way
now exchange the pawns boris
well this is yeah it's over
yeah congratulations to zero
but
oh my wow
nine seconds uh what did we should do
so far so good or not and
actually was silly finished just one
point behind sweden
i think yeah
oh he blundered his spawn okay this is
on
this okay but still
but here after bishop e3 knight e5
db the e6 wins
bishop f4 e7 yeah but k6 i think it's
still a draw
but of course it's more challenging okay
yes king d6
yeah i think that's exactly type of
situation we discussed with jan
when in those end games like knight and
two pawns against bishop
and one home sometimes it looks like
night it's completely winning and it's a
draw
and here it doesn't even look like it's
so it should definitely be
well so that was it
are we getting more armageddons i lost
track of all the action
aleko and ding they are still playing
there are game four actually they're
rapid games
ah okay
and i think it's a draw then they won
the match right
yeah it doesn't look like lake oh will
win this does it
we're being joined by boris gelfant
who just won his armageddon against
yamny pomneshi
boris congratulations
we can't hear you yet maybe there's some
unmute button or something to be pressed
yeah okay not the best quality match but
okay
but the armageddon you played very well
i might imagine i played really well
yeah yeah i think i played well
no real blunders yeah first game is uh
horrible yeah and then
okay miracle save yeah okay
not the highest quality games today but
okay what to do yeah
overall how do you feel did you enjoy
the tournament yeah i enjoyed very much
it's a bit you know
hard for me in my age yeah to have four
such
games against such strong players each
day with no
breaks but okay i really enjoyed it you
had to play
as i said first day it's a big privilege
to play against such a
strong field and such a interesting
event so i really enjoyed it
and i think had a lot of interesting
games okay match with magnus was
horrible
but other matches were
a very close fight yeah sometimes i lost
concentration and blundered but
also my opponents did so okay
how was your experience to play online
is it uh
it's your first tournament right yeah
okay i played some blitz tournaments but
basically that's it yeah no it's okay i
think if i had some
uh once or twice had mouse sleep yeah
but
this slid larry i made some senseless
movie i just mouse
mostly but my position was bad anyway
sorry how much can you concentrate
comparing a real
rapid tournament game no i think i
i can concentrate uh more or less the
same yeah
okay i see it in front yeah okay
all of us uh learned already what is
computer so
i think uh to focus it's another story
sometimes okay
you have lapse of concentration but it's
because of
it happens yeah because we are humans
not because of
uh you know it's online during
oversupport games i also have
a lot of laps of concentration yeah
maybe some other players
they have it they either don't have this
problem but i personally have it through
my whole career so do you think
in the long run if you compare a
tournament of offline
do you think the quality should be more
or less the same
well i think i was always thought that
we should compare
apples with apples and oranges with
oranges yeah
you know all this online's tournament
objectively you know
it's uh you know players play for fun
okay okay all of us are ambitious
players yeah
but it's totally different that compared
if you play okay
some big event or you know world
championship or something
yes how is your working on chess
routine these days because i was very
impressed with
a lot of the openings you had with white
this game against kramnik and so on
what's your schedule studying chess
these days
no i started a lot but also you know
today you know there are no many
tournaments and also i give a lot of
like online camps so i
work maybe less on openings and more on
middle games and end games preparing
materials
but also when i do it you know my rule
that i never switch on engine so i keep
my head working
because i know i think it's not fair
towards
the students
who are some of them are extremely
strong players and can be
part of easily part of this tournament
or
at least a very high level and also not
very good for me
if i'll you know take a rest
and they look at the engine so i try to
work together with the young
players on you know middle games or
end games also you know completed two
new books uh
recently so also quite an intensive work
should be out this in couple of months
yeah
so thank you for watching
yeah decision making in a technical
decision-making and i forgot how we call
it
basically it's rook and queen end game
and the rook and queen
game my i think it's called minor peace
ending yeah
very much looking forward to those i've
mentioned many times on the show
when i got your book on positional
decision making i read it immediately in
one session it was a great pleasure so
congrats on those books
very much thank you thank you i it's
nice because i
me and also my co-author we put a lot of
effort in this book so it's very nice to
hear that it's
appreciated thank you very much thank
you so much boris was a pleasure to
watch you play
all the best thank you thank you and
they say
good luck and we keep on following uh
those four guys who qualified yeah
by all means congrats boris it was nice
to see you playing and fighting yeah
thank you
thank you okay guys
bye bye alexander bye bye
all right i guess all the games are
over peter laco drew against ding
learing no winning chances there
so ding wins that match won't make him
much happier we also say
bye to alexander grishouk i guess who we
will see
during the semi-finals and hopefully
finals alexander any last words
yeah i just wanted to say there will be
a very
interesting semifinals i hope peter puts
up a real fight against magnus
and the nepalese against gilly it's a
sort of continuation of their matches uh
anish won the semi-final in the previous
tournament
and jan won their match in this
tournament
i think jan had like maybe minus
14 if you combine the evaluation of
all four games during this match and
still he won
very convincingly so let's see what
happens
this one is guaranteed
will be very interesting and but i hope
that
another match will be very interesting
as well
i'm very much looking forward to it as
well
judit what are your closing thoughts
who's going to win the whole thing
and all that oh
well of course it's always magnus who is
the the candidate but i think
the candidate to win he's the favorite
but i i see honey very
much challenging everybody and he's
capable of
of doing anything and beat anybody i'm
pretty sure we're going to have exciting
games
and um well anything can happen but i
think it will depend on what kind of day
they
wake up and magnus won this match also
but he made mistakes i think he's not
playing his the best so he can still
uh improve his play even though of
course it seems like he's
crushing everybody i mean by the score
table
uh but if he makes mistakes then
i think the others can might catch him
so it's going to be very tight and
interesting
so in the rapid games
everything is possible as we saw in
different games you make a mistake and
if the other one catches the opportunity
then anything can happen and if it gets
to armageddon then it's about
mao's game as we said it so anything
is possible i'm very much looking
forward for the matches because all
players are giving great
ideas unexpected ideas and
a lot of fun yeah
absolutely tomorrow is a day off of
course there will be
more action on chess24.com so
paid a visit if you guys want to support
this series of tournaments
we'll be back the day after tomorrow i
think unit gets one more day off
but then we'll be back to join us thanks
everybody for watching
and let's hand it over to tanya to bring
home the show
see you guys the day after tomorrow see
you
bye thank you yan you did
and sasha for that very insightful day
of chess
and the action of the preliminaries
comes to an
end for semi-finalists it's
goodbye for the other six players but
what a journey they've had
uh this is our bracket going into the
semis we've got
an encore of the chesapeal masters
semi-finals
with anish facing yan in that one
in the chesapeake masters it was an
anish giri show
in this event as as sasha pointed out
yan was came out of literally the grave
and took that match he was down
majorly in both the games i'm sure yan's
taken some big takeaways from both these
matches and he's gonna come back strong
because
it's it's a lot at stake magnus carlsen
versus peter swiddler tough for peter to
be up against a very in-shape magnus i
was watching his interview
with the yan earlier and it's a bit to
be honest it's a bit
annoying that when he scored nine out of
nine he's won
all his matches against these greatest
players and still there's this i mean
it's a sign of a champion of a true
world champion i guess
but there's still this feeling of you
know what i didn't play
that well and uh i mean magnus if you
did not play that
well and you still scored nine out of
nine won
all your matches then there's really no
hope for anyone
but we've got these are our four
semi-finalists as you see and let's also
just quickly update everybody with the
finals of the
uh magnus carlsen chester so as we were
speaking about it earlier
magnus carlsen daniel duboff hikaru
nakamura
are all in the three out of four spots
are these guys
and the fourth spot is going to be
either
ding lyran yana pomnyacchi
anishkiri or peter swiddler one of these
four
will make it to the final either ways
it's going to be an exciting event but
before that we've of course got the
semis tomorrow is a break day but the
chest
does not stop we do have a q a with
yan tomorrow uh and there it is uh so do
join us for that
you've got to be premium to be able to
ask yan
all the questions that you want to today
that was
that was an uh interesting match he had
with boris it almost looked like that
was a very
not motivated yan and i think that could
be that could be yan's um
i don't want to see a big flaw but i
think that's something that he probably
struggles with at times
when he's in shape and fired up he is
an absolute monster but very often uh we
see him collapsing
in ways which you can't explain and it
almost felt like
you know with his expressions how he was
smiling and laughing like
because he'd already booked his spot
right he was already second i think that
was a little bit of a motivation thing
today
completely winning positions messed up
the armageddon
brilliantly played by boris but an
unexpected result there
also a quick reminder to all of you to
register before 31st of july
to book your spot for for a symbol
against magnus carlsen
and um this will be the time control
will be 30 minutes
with 30 second increment for the symbol
so that's
that's a that's a pretty good time to be
able to to give a fight there
lots of lots of people have signed up so
there will probably be
more than one symbol but the first one
is on the 7th of august remember you
need to extend or buy the membership
before 31st july
and if you want to prepare for this um
for this moment then don't forget to
check out
all the resources the the various series
available on chess24.com by the world
champion himself
there is a series by former world
champion vishyanan by magnus carlson by
peter swiddler
by jan gustafsson it's an immense
library of many resources and you've got
unlimited access to that if you go
premium there's a 40
off deal going on some very cool march
as well check out the shop tomorrow is a
rest day not just for the players but
the commentators as well
and um yes i think we all need it
uh i look forward to seeing you guys for
the sammies
alright take care see you soon
try brushing your teeth with the
opposite hand of what you would normally
use
if it's too easy you can also balance on
one leg at the same time
when you break even the simple routines
you can challenge your brain to
strengthen
underused nerve cells
so
my name is sebastian milov
and i bring to you along with the world
champion
magnus carson the wonderful app tactics
frenzy sold millions of unique
high quality and entertaining chess
puzzles that have all been
quality checked by strong grandmasters
like you and the camera and young gustav
become a member today and compete
for monthly prizes sponsored by
chessable
just24 magnus trainer
and of course king himself
magnus carlson we have made sure
that no matter how good you are at chess
you can
enjoy this app and get the challenge
of your life alireza varuja
alexander grishik sergey karjakin among
a lot of elite players they all love the
app
and i can assure you you will as well
download the app today and become a
chess
champion
for most chess players it has never been
about becoming the next greatest
but about defining your own path your
own style of play
nobody could define that for you but
perfecting your style
takes practice introducing alex astane
lopez
international master
train smart play smart
cochest.com
well